good morning
the time being 10 a.m We will open uh
house the hearing on House Bill 60 and
we will recognize the prime sponsor
representative petrucic
thank you madam chair
ladies and gentlemen of the Ways and
Means Committee a representative petusic
from Rockingham 13 which is Derry
for the record
I'm here to
introduce House Bill 60 camping fees for
non-residents my constituent was
supposed to be here
uh he's a chiropractor so he may be busy
and if there is any written testimony I
will get it from him and forward it to
the chair or the clerk for distribution
to the committee
the reason why can can everybody hear me
thank you the reason why I put this in
for my constituent is that he is a
camper big time he has rebuilt a vintage
1980s Airstream
from the inside out it's worth a lot of
buckos and he camps all over New England
he keeps camps in New Hampshire when he
goes to Massachusetts he gets very upset
because they charge out of state
residents out of state rates
we in New Hampshire do not
and he is going why don't we charge a
little bit more to out-of-state campers
to come to New Hampshire to our great
wonderful White Mountain State
when they charge us a lot more to camp
on their beaches and their little bumps
called mountains out in the western part
of Massachusetts
for if we charge 25 a night here they
charge 55 a night down in Massachusetts
for the same type of camping and he and
the campers Association which he is part
of are very upset that they get ripped
off when they have to go to
Massachusetts for meetings or on the
regional camping associations and that
is why I put in the bill he's very upset
about the pricing
he hopes that New Hampshire would
consider
up charging out-of-state residents uh
some more money which is basically free
income for our great wonderful Granite
State and uh oh yeah the reservation
system
when you go to Pawtuckaway during the
summer you can see nothing but white and
red license plates
because they get in early they get the
reservations and if you live in New
Hampshire you go in try to get a
reservation anywhere say south of
Concord
you can't if you go further up in the
state you'll get a reservation
but you'll still see a lot of white and
red license plates and it's it should be
nice if New Hampshire residents had
priority
on reservations so that they could get
in and camp in their own state
and then open it up to anybody else who
wants to come in at an out of state
pricing
so it's more Revenue it's New Hampshire
resident favorable
and uh if he were here I wish he could
talk about it more but like I said he's
a chiropractor and he may have uh
clients that he couldn't uh change
so that is my testimony
and I if anybody has any questions I'd
be happy to take them
yes representative plett yes thank you
representative
spelling name right I know another
person who calls himself pot a check so
I've been called a lot of different
names by a lot of different people and
my students back when I was teaching
Middle School it was Mr P okay uh anyway
do you have any Revenue estimate does
this has been about the squat isn't it
pretty much its principle I don't have
any information from him if he was here
he would have had all the information uh
what I will do is I'll contact him and
if he does have some some information
testimony or documentation that I can uh
pass out to you I'll get it to the chair
or to representative genagian or
representative Platt
ideally if you could have him email the
entire committee house Ways and Means I
uh
good morning I'm representative Ames uh
you mentioned the campers Association
as a group that your constituents are
part of and that they're supportive of
this initiative I assume that uh uh an
association of people who go to camps
not campgrounds and what I'm wondering
is uh a if that's correct and if they're
taking a position on this legislation
and then B whether there's a campground
Association or Campground some kind of
grouping that has expressed interest in
this matter and if so what their
possession would be
I didn't get a lot of that
representative I can barely hear you but
the information that I could make out I
got is from uh from my constituent
I mean I'm not
privy to the information that he has is
the association that he belongs to of
campers of New England uh as far as I
know the information I would I would not
take you know without the veracity of it
so I'm just taking it as as his word
thank you representative Doucette thank
you madam chair and thank you for taking
my question representative
um is there any information you you uh
mentioned giving priority to New
Hampshire Citizens First it's not
there's nothing in this proposed bill
that talks to that and I guess I'm just
wondering if there's other states that
do that because I'm kind of curious as
to the constitutionality of of the State
of New Hampshire being able to do
something of that nature and to Echo
what representative uh Platt said
uh we probably need some testimony from
the revenue side of things and how that
would work and I understand it does
happen in other states but the
prioritization of New Hampshire Citizens
First
you mentioned it it's not in the piece
here I'm just wondering what your
thought process is on that thank you
thank you for the question uh
representative Duke Set uh like I said
my constituent has all the information I
just put this in for him but we have
talked about it he said yeah they do
they do have priority for in-state
residents at some of these states uh
when they take reservations from their
own residence first
and then they open it up to out of state
so I'm just looking at reciprocation and
it's just a recommendation this bill has
nothing casting concrete it's just a
recommendation uh to look at the pricing
and if if they wanted to I'm sure that
they could take it upon himself to look
at a reservation system
I mean we don't have to direct them to
them of course I'm quite sure that if
there's Revenue to be had
uh they could they could do it on their
own
thank you madam chair on
to the division of parks to the
Department of Natural and cultural
representative uh we just had a 10
minute conversation
and uh I think their testimony will be
interesting
thank you and you if I could follow up
if you're con did the department of the
division of parks may know this but on
what on what does Massachusetts and the
others what do they do about students
residents in prep schools and colleges
in this state and Military on leave
whether they have special Provisions
rather than just resident non-resident I
thank you so much for your testimony uh
any other questions for Representative
petrucic no thank you so much thank you
madam chair
I don't have any other pink cards is
please fill out a pink card and send it
Ryan are you ready to go ahead and give
your testimony welcome to ways and means
please introduce yourself tell us your
good morning Madam chair and committee
members my name is Brian Wilson I am the
uh director of the division of uh Parks
and Recreation also known as New
um and um thank you for receiving my
testimony this morning
um please accept this testimony on
behalf of on behalf of the Department of
Natural and cultural resources division
of Parks and Recreation regarding hb60
camping fees for non-residents
the department appreciates the concern
of the Bill's sponsor we respectfully
provide the committee with the following
information the department already has
the statute statutory authority to set
its camping fees
pursuant to RSA 216 a3g the commissioner
of the Department of Natural and
cultural resources in consultation with
the director of Parks and Recreation
shall establish fees for access to use
of the state park system the fees
approved by the commissioner after prior
prior approval of the fiscal committee
shall not be subject to the provisions
of RSA 541a so as to provide the
department with the ability to maximize
res revenues and to adjust fees
according to market conditions and
Trends as is the common practice in
Private Industry
pursuant to RSA 216a1 the intent of the
general court that accomp it is the
intent of the general court that a
comprehensive State Park system shall be
developed operated and maintained to
achieve four purposes which include
continually providing Park areas and
Facilities as may be necessary to meet
the recreational need of the citizens of
all regions of the state as well to
encourage and support tourism and
related economic activity in the state
the department just strives to balance
these priorities in part by continually
examining fee structures visitation data
and other metrics to inform
recommendations for adjustments to
camping fees
the department has considered a separate
fee schedule for non-residents who
access state parks campgrounds however
with 65 percent of our campers coming
from out of state we are concerned that
campers will elect to go elsewhere
thereby resulting in a negative
Financial impact to the self-funded
state park system Additionally the land
and water conservation fund monies that
were used to develop and improve state
park campgrounds under the lwcf program
rules it prohibits unequal access to
lwcf funded public lands based on
residency
we recognize that some New Hampshire
campers experience difficulties in
reserving the campsite and dates of
their choice as many in the outdoor
industry can attest the covid-19
pandemic created a much greater than
normal interest in Outdoor Pursuits the
division has made great strides in
improving the campground reservation
process over the years this Trends
includes a great emphasis on online
reservations which account for 94
percent of all of our reservations
versus three percent that call from a
call center fulfillment additionally the
division has implemented a lottery
reservation system which levels the
playing field with respect to the
opening of inventory and many Savvy
Savvy campers knowing to reserve the
very minute inventory becomes available
this program is very successful at
Hampton Beach State Park campground and
Jericho Mountain State Park both which
see some of the system's highest
occupancy rates thank you for the
opportunity to provide testimony and
additional information on hb60 pursuant
to RS say 216 a3g the department
currently has the authority to set fees
including fees charged to non-residents
thank you for your testimony are you
open to questions absolutely great
representative pled
I always think of questions
um have you done a survey of what the
fees are in other states to see whether
if we went up a little bit we'd still be
competitive yes we have
um we continually do this and as most
recently approximately a year ago
um there was a comprehensive report
provided by our our staff that was
shared with the state park advisory
Council who advises the director on
policy of the state park system and at
the time there were considerations and
even some recommendations for increases
to fees for non-residents and and
consultation with the governor's office
at that time it was determined that it
wasn't going to move forward at that
time however
um as as I indicated in the testimony we
have the ability to continue to do so
and um and we'll be doing reviewing
doing that again with our state park
thank you on you it used to be that you
were severely underfunded in money for
Park maintenance
is that still the case and is would hire
fees in certain areas work work for you
for that and on is there the possibility
of having higher fees in the more
popular parks that are hard to get
reservations in
thank you representative
um the state park system is designed to
be operationally self-funded
um and
um we have done a very good job of
establishing our programs and our
operations both on our revenue and
expense side
to remain solvent
um and are I would say in in very good
Financial Health
the asterisk to that that I would I
would add is that
um it was not by Design created to
provide for Capital Improvements which
can be in tens and or in our case uh
hundreds of millions of dollars in
backlog of deferred maintenance however
operationally we we've been doing very
well
um and a lot of that revenue does go
back uh for operational maintenance of
our Park system and and part of the
design for us to have the ability to
review our fee structure and create
changes to that is is in part to help
continually be able to make sure that we
are competitive and kind of striking
that balance of creating accessible
opportunities both for residents and
non-residents that are affordable but
representative Ellery
thank you madam chair
um this lwcf fund
um who sets the rules and uh who manages
the program sure uh the lwcf is the land
and water conservation fund it's a
program administered by the National
Park Service so through the department
of interior
um it's a federal program
um to which all 50 states uh participate
and have received tens of millions of
dollars since uh since it's been
established I believe in the mid 60s
primarily for recreational outdoor
recreational lands acquisition and
recreational improvements
um virtually every single Campground
within the park system has received lwcf
requirement on
um basically uh against discrimination
based on residency so for that there was
some comments earlier with respect to
the timing of reservations so this is
something that we've looked at
previously and have found under guidance
from the National Park Service that we
cannot allow for earlier reservations
for residents
um than non-residents however we do have
the ability to provide for a separate
fee structure as long as within uh
within reason
right
follow up follow up quickly yes uh thank
you uh from your previous testimony it
was under the impression that no state
could uh charge two separate fees but
you can charge you're now saying that a
separate fee for a non-resident is
allowed under the lwcf rules and uh that
can be set by the states under their own
rules
and since we have a lot of experience
doing that with cigarettes and you're
only allowed we want better too uh with
cigarettes and alcohol and everything
else I should not be that much of a
difficulty to
undertake such an activity and still cut
the undercut every other state
would you believe
[Laughter]
representative Malloy
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question
Mr Wilson I would uh for my own purposes
I would like to see some context here
just how much money we're talking about
what is the revenue from the fees now
what are we thinking about is there a
number for that and then I can
in my own view I can take a look at
what changes might happen if we change
fees and that sort of thing that's all
thank you if I could see the revenue
number that's my question thank you
is that something that um we I I'm happy
to share with with the committee here I
have a few figures
um that may provide some context so in
uh 2022 the calendar year
um the division brought in three point a
little over 3.8 million dollars in
camping fees across the um uh Campground
system
um that's uh equates to 50 a little over
56 000 separate reservations and
um our camper account for 2022 included
000 campers visited throughout the
system and again uh about approximately
65 percent of that revenue and and those
other figures for that matter uh are
equated to out-of-state visitation
representative uh doucets
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question you you mentioned in
your testimony that the uh the fees
self-fund the department
um except for Capital expenditures I'm
kind of curious as to whether we can get
some kind of report and see as to what
the revenues were I'm making the natural
assumption that the profit margin might
have been a little ticked up in the last
couple years uh we have a great product
a great state for people to come to and
and they did so I'm wondering where
those revenues if you're in the black do
those come back to the general fund
through those uh sustain another program
within the department I'm just kind of
curious if you can speak to that sure
um thank you representative
um so the uh the state park fund uh
generally what what how we refer to it
is a non-lapsing fund
um set up that revolves
um so uh the the state park system has
the unique ability to be run and uh in
Enterprise
um perspective that um any year that we
operate in the black we maintain a
balance
um that carry over carries over uh
carries forward each year and that has
been the case for several years so it's
been it's been a long time I believe
leave since the state's Park system has
operated in the red
however there is also statutory language
that sets a minimum requirement for that
fund to maintain and as uh we know in
the outdoor recreation industry it
doesn't take much uh bad weather or or a
tough season for things to kind of go in
the other direction so that's why we are
both kind of very cognizant of how we're
managing that on a year-to-year basis
representative jinnegan thank you madam
chair thank you for taking my question
um on the second left last paragraph you
end with the lwcf program rules
prohibits unequal access
um to lwcf funded public lands so I
guess
um a little confused when you when you
then said that um
States could charge
non-residents different rates doesn't
charging a different rate cause unequal
access
um
according to the uh National Park
Service no
um it it it doesn't
um the
um it's more
um on the timing of the accessibility
that so that each and every day there's
the equal access uh afforded to
Residents and non-residents as far as
coming
um but it doesn't
directly speak to the fee structure uh
in that and part of the reason for us
including that uh here was um we just
wanted to be clear that
um there's a differentiation I think
we've kind of touched on it here as well
of both the timing and the ability for
residents to get free access over uh
non-residents in in addition to a
separate fee structure which are two
separate things thank you
thank you madam chair
um we've
could you tell us how much uh you're
operating total operating costs were in
22 and also on what is the value of your
backlog of maintenance
um thank you representative
um I
will have to get you the total operating
uh budget uh figures
um full disclosure I've been on board
here two months in my appointment so I
haven't uh set all of those uh facts and
figures uh to memory just yet but I'll
be happy to provide that
um I do know uh roughly our our Capital
backlog over the three bienniums for
which we've provided uh a capital plan
we are upwards of a hundred million
dollars in uh Capital uh
okay I think that's all we have for
questions thank you so much thank you
I don't see any other pink cards is
there anyone else here to testify on
House Bill 60.
Jennifer is there anyone signed in on a
okay great all right I was seeing no
more presentations I will close the
good morning
we will now open the public hearing on
House Bill 121
the chair recognizes the prime sponsor
representative Schoenberg
thank you madam chair
uh before I begin there will be folders
passed out to you at the end of my
presentation so that all of you will
have
the presentation and any other side
notes or documents
thank you madam chair and thank you Ways
and Means for the opportunity to present
House Bill 121
I am representative Tom Schamberg from
Merrimack six the towns of Wilmette like
a dog a mutt and Sutton
uh House Bill 121 FN is an act relative
to worldwide combined reporting for
unitary businesses under the business
profits tax this bill would repeal the
water's edge combined group provisions
of the business profits tax in
consultation with Madam chair and
ranking member representative almi this
presentation will be a thirty thousand
foot overview of making the New
Hampshire tax structure more Equitable
by requiring multinationals to pay their
fair share eliminating the unfair
Advantage they currently enjoy at the
expense of New Hampshire businesses and
domestic companies
tax policy created by this committee and
passed by the New Hampshire legislature
should be
to make sure that New Hampshire policies
enable the state to meet its obligations
to our citizens
while assuring a fair and Level Playing
Field for all businesses operating in
New Hampshire in paying their true
profits tax
the problem is that by implementing in
the 1986 legislature the water's edge
method of Taxation on the recommendation
of the New Hampshire Ways and Means
Committee
it provided unintended consequences for
the past 37 years that grants a tax
advantage to foreign-based corporations
with U.S subsidiaries operating in New
Hampshire
the tax advantage is caused when
domestic or New Hampshire companies
cannot use the same accounting tools
that multinationals use when engaged in
many inter-corporate transactions with
their foreign subsidiary located in New
Hampshire when determining their
business profits tax those tools are
called intangibles the intangible assets
lack physical existence and are not
financial instruments
the process
by these multinational inter-corporate
transactions with their New Hampshire
subsidiary or subsidiaries is to reduce
their State corporate income tax
liability which leads to tax avoidance
of an estimated Revenue dollar amount of
140 to 170 million dollars each year
the solution to this tax avoidance is to
treat the parent and it's integrated and
interconnected subsidiaries as a single
taxable entity
this is known as unitary combined
reporting or formulary apportionment on
a worldwide basis
is the present water's edge method of
Taxation on a fair and Level Playing
Field for New Hampshire companies and
domestic unitary businesses
I don't believe so but there is a
position stated in 1999 13 years after
New Hampshire adopted the water's edge
taxation method by the New Hampshire
Supreme Court when they decided the case
of caterpillar Incorporated
quote we point out that the water's edge
method was adopted for the benefit of
foreign businesses
the court statement points to an unlevel
unfair playing field between U.S
domestic based corporations and New
Hampshire companies and foreign-based
corporations under the water edge method
versus a Level Playing Field under
worldwide combined reporting as
visualize generating additional hundreds
of millions of dollars in revenue for
Education Health environment safety and
so forth
the action that is needed by the New
Hampshire house Ways and Means Committee
is a policy of tax reform that moves
towards simplification
transparency
fairness and a Level Playing Field
some side notes the state of New
Hampshire moved toward market-based
sourcing and single sales Factor
apportionment
without proposed studies to provide data
before enacting legislation
The Honorable Patrick abrami retired
representative chair of ways and means
Norman major
present ranking member of ways and means
representative Susan almi and
representative Ames fought legislation
that came over from the other body that
enacted legislation without waiting for
the necessary data to move forward that
would give this committee the necessary
data to understand
and state revenues under the two
legislative enactments and the possible
unintended consequences
presently there is a commission formed
under house bill 1022 in the 2022
session
that is presently being chaired by
representative spilsberry of our Ways
and Means Committee the commission is
reviewing the fairness of the water's
edge method between domestic
corporations and multinational
corporations operating in the United
States the commission presently is not
fully populated per house bill 102.
as per my discussion with Madam chair
Sanborn I have put together
in the folders one a summary and
methodology report from The Institute on
Taxation and economic policy itep and
salesfactor.org
two there is a letter from the White
House classified as Secret in 1984 and
Declassified on March 28 2000 on unitary
taxation to Margaret Thatcher prime
minister that led eventually to New
Hampshire's 1986 Water's Edge taxation
and third there's an article in the
folder printed in tax notes on August
3rd 2020 by this representative called
the inequality project the America we
need
I appreciate your attention today on
this overview
Jen and hope to have further discussion
after you review
after your review of this material
this war is passing out though okay
great thank you so much is that was that
your question representative mommy yes
okay representative Platt yes I heard
you say there's a commission studying
this retired by
uh representative spilsbury represent
yes why is this not premature until that
commission does its work when this uh
commission met
uh it didn't meet till after the
election time in November and we were
given the opportunity
to put in bills as Representatives that
were here in the 2022 session and
knowing the unpredictability
of electors and the way they vote
I wanted to put this bill in in case
representative putt that I did not get
reelected
um once I got reelected the bill was
already in the hopper but I think that
with 11 members here out of 20 that have
never heard or seen this bill it was
good to present this
so that you could get an idea of
what is going on in in our tax World
especially for Ways and Means
I am hoping that this committee will at
least
look at this material and move it to
another date where we could just have a
further discussion before we go with a
recommendation on what we should do with
and thank you Miss Moore thank you
representative
okay we will uh one other question yes
or Matt May I asked Madam chair yes uh
we received a
um
email with an attachment
from the console on state taxation
uh I think it was sent out by your
office
and I just wonder will that be discussed
today or should we wait for that for
another time period if we're going to
move this forward
I think we should probably wait we have
a few other speakers after yourself and
then we do have this ongoing commission
that I would encourage any member who's
interested in this topic to please
attend the commission hearings and
meetings
um which will be probably scheduled at
some point in the near future so please
engage yourself with that it'll probably
be next October
thank you madam chair oh we have one
thank you representative for taking my
question
have you spoken with the like the trade
Industries like Bia or one of those I'm
considering several large corporations
that do business in uh Nashua Hudson
Merrimack
um
that would be directly involved with
this and are
huge Employers in the in the state and
have
the wherewithal just to say to hell with
it
should this be adversely
uh affecting them have you discussed
this with any of the industry
individuals
thank you for your question
representative ulrey uh two years ago I
was invited by the Bia for a zoom
when I had House Bill 102 and
there were 30 members there and I made
the presentation of that bill the same
bill worldwide combined reporting and
the one comment that stuck in my mind
from that was there's only a few of us
that would be doing it it's not really
important and
then they went on to cheer the tax rate
reduction that went into effect later in
that session
that's the only contact I've had with
follow-up clarifying question please no
it's a question uh of the chair oh
and it would be appropriate that I
believe to get uh these can you get
closer to the microphone
thank you I I think it would be
appropriate if we got some input from
the industries that would be directly
affected by that we all know the
initials of them
um most of them are located in Merrimack
uh but
I think we're going to need some input
from them thank you madam chair thank
you
thank you for coming all right oh sorry
representative Ami
thank you I just hope that this
commission will be able to get started
long before October because this is a
complex issue
I'm sure there are some representatives
of the people that would not like to see
us going back to what was being done
almost universally in New in new on in
the United States
um
four decades ago five
thank you thank you and you have teed up
our next speaker who is representative
spilsbury who is chair of said
Commission
thank you madam chairman good morning
Ways and Means members
um I have no prepared remarks but just
want to bring the committee up to date
so I'm representative Walter spilsbury
known as Terry
representing Sullivan District 3 towns
of Charlestown Newport and unity
and I'm an appointed member of the
commission
that was created following passage in
the last session of hb102
and that's been codified here RSA 77
a23b
the commission
is
assigned
the following the commission shall study
the advantages and disadvantages for the
state's economy and revenues of
replacement of the current water's edge
method by the worldwide combined
reporting method
for reporting and apportionment of
income under the business profits tax
it shall consult with national experts
in both methods including economists
business associations and tax experts
so hb102
established a structure including 12
members
a three to be appointed by the Speaker
of the House
one to be appointed by the Senate
President
and eight to come from business and
industry and in
very much in accord with representative
ulery's comments to ensure that there is
representation within the commission's
deliberations not merely from those who
might choose to testify
the
the commission has met twice
we met October 10th and selected a
representative abrami as our chairman
and we discussed generally what road map
we would like to follow
we agreed that we would file an interim
report uh November 1st with the speaker
and Senate President and that that has
been done and I'll ensure that everybody
on the committee receives a copy of this
brief report with a couple of
attachments totaling five pages
uh what the report essentially uh
indicates is that the legislation gives
us until November 1st 2023
to complete our study and report back to
the legislature and I think that's
somewhat unusual where a commission is
crossing over a term into a new
legislature
so this provides us an additional 10
months from now
to examine the issue and to to come back
yes representative Ami
we would get going before October the
there are a couple of hurdles
the first is that uh two members are not
back in the legislature this year so
there is a vacancy to be filled by the
speaker of the house and one by the
Senate President
and we met a second time November uh
I think it was the
the
tenth which uh oddly was two days after
the election
so it was it was so much ironing
experience because not not everybody
who's on the commission was re-elected
so we agreed we would not meet again
until these vacancies could be filled
in addition uh members who have been
appointed are Kevin Kennedy business and
industry Association Alex freeze New
Hampshire Department of Business and
economic Affairs Matthew Foley New
Hampshire Society of certified public
accountants and Keon Wong who's with us
today New Hampshire Department of
Revenue Administration and these members
did participate in our meetings
but that leaves four other positions
that the statute provides for that have
never been filled one for the New
Hampshire Attorney General's office one
for the New Hampshire Bar Association
and two more from the New Hampshire
business and industry Association the
reason that there are multiple positions
from nhbia is to ensure that there are
that each major sector of large
businesses and domestic business smaller
independent businesses are represented
so
the timing
is that with a Full Slate of business I
think that uh it's premature for the
commission to meet and until the
vacancies are filled it's premature for
the commission to meet but in discussion
with our chairman
um and ranking member we've talked about
having the commission resume at the end
of winter
upbeat several times this spring
potentially continue during the summer
and make sure that we're in a position
to get our recommendations formulated
and submitted hopefully well in advance
of November 1st
so with all of those considerations in
mind
I would like to make the recommendation
that the Ways and Means Committee retain
this bill
it's premature in the time frame that we
have to consider bills to reach a
decision either OTP or itl and a
retained bill would be taken back up by
Ways and Means in the fall we can
coordinate that timing make sure that
the commission's conclusions you know
are fully considered and and framed and
that I think would put us in a position
where the bill could be dealt with in
January on the house floor
representative orrs
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question so having worked in
the business world
we seem to be moving at the speed of
Euro to turtle and I'm not
saying that uh inappropriate but it's
like why do we have to wait until spring
to get a couple of these people from via
on board or
fill these other slots I mean to me it
seems like we ought to be
push pushing this instead of waiting for
it to come to us
okay fair question
first of all I can't account for why the
four vacancies were never filled but
even if they had been I think that the
interruption of the legislative members
won in the house and one in the Senate
would require us to pause until
they're in place second
uh your urinal the turtle metaphor is is
is good but uh let's bear in mind this
is an extraordinarily complex
uh topic this is
a layer of complexity upon layer of
complexity upon layer of complexity this
is a topic that has been litigated to
the United States Supreme Court three
times
actually four cases in in 82 83 and 96
incidentally I had the pleasure as a
Young attorney
of participating in the drafting of a
brief to the United States Supreme Court
in the Shell Oil case
California
and um
that was the cause of my getting
admitted to the United States Supreme
Court bar so this is bringing me around
to a topic we were discussing
40 years ago
and um
I I would just make a comment uh
representative Schamberg indicated that
their unintended consequences from the
uh 19
86 law I I'm not sure that that's
exactly the phrase that I would use
because I think that actually the
consequences were largely contemplated
and known I think that there are so many
trade-offs involved in the question of
uh the complexity of the tax fine that
would be required if we would if we
repeal the water's edge method uh in the
Conformity with other states and the
competitive questions that that would
raise in the Conformity with the current
uh rules adopted by the United States
Congress in the Internal Revenue Service
so um
I think it needs further deliberation
and I don't think this topic has
received careful deliberation in
at least since 1996.
thank you very much
excellent answers
and uh there's been some updates to the
house rules my understanding of them at
the current time is that if you testify
on a bill then you shouldn't also be
asking questions of other testifiers but
that you can sit in your seat and
otherwise be engaged we will continue to
get clarification on that if we hear
more from the community services
department
okay I would like to recognize Thomas
over I think that's his name from the
Coalition was it
opal all right okay from the Coalition
for a prosperous America thank you so
thank you madam chair
um and it's probably my handwriting that
caused the difficulty
um I am uh Thomas Opel
um I am the head of a small consulting
firm O2 strategies based in Canaan New
Hampshire my home but I'm here today
representing
the Coalition for prosperous America in
support of Representative Schamberg's
bill
um HB 121
um
understanding the uh
pregame discussions I should say
um I'm going to try and keep this at a
60 foot 60 000 foot level
um we uh we are very strongly in support
of Representative Schamberg's bill but
we understand that
with new members in the committee that
there and the commission the existing
commission
the idea of retaining the bill for
further study makes a lot of sense
um we'd like to see quicker action but
we support the idea of of working with
the commission and representative
spilsbury will make an excellent chair
of that commission and we'll look
forward to working with him
um I think you know fundamentally
representative Schamberg I think
outlined the the parameters of why
he introduced this bill and why we
support it and it and it fundamentally
comes down to leveling the playing field
for
the vast majority of businesses in the
state of New Hampshire
there was a study recently
the global business Alliance not a
particular fan of this bill
but even they acknowledge that
more than nine out of ten workers in New
Hampshire work in companies that are not
multinational companies that would not
be would only be positively impacted by
this bill and when I say positively
impacted right now
if you have a small coffee shop if you
have a small Brew Pub a restaurant some
small business that is competing with a
multinational like a Starbucks or
ambev or some major international
corporation
you're paying a different tax rate in a
sense than they are because they have
the ability perfectly legal but they
have the ability
um through accounting methods to shift
profits and
defer the amount of taxes that they
would rightfully owe to the state of New
Hampshire
that small coffee shop doesn't have the
same advantage
um and so at the end of the day
either
those companies that employ more than
nine out of ten workers in New Hampshire
are paying more than their fair share to
make up the difference uh or the state
of New Hampshire is losing Revenue as
representative Schamberg said there's a
study out there that says 140 to 170
million dollars and it was done by three
organizations that are all 501 c3s
non-partisan under the IRS rules so
fundamentally that's why we are
supporting this bill
we intend to work with representative
spilsbury as the commission moves
forward one of the things that we would
hope
is that people who don't often get their
voice heard in Concord
because they're small business people
and they're working
you know and they don't have either the
time to come to conquer themselves they
don't have the ability to hire
professional lobbyists
and they very often their voices don't
get heard and and often they're not
fully aware of what's being considered
in the legislature
one of the things that we hope to do is
working with representative spilsbury is
making sure that that sector of New
Hampshire economy which provides most of
the jobs in the state that that sector
is represented and and heard so that
when the commission finishes with its
recommendations
each of your members you all have those
kinds of businesses in your districts
you can be confident that that sector
has been heard from as well
that's fundamentally
my statement I I do have a uh a written
statement that was uh passed around I
think you all have copies of it
um but I'll stop there and happy to
answer any questions
um of a non-technical nature
representative Almy
thank you madam chair
on
Tom
can you tell us more about the Coalition
for pros prosperous America
how big is it where is it based sure so
the Coalition is based in Washington DC
it is a non-profit it represents the
interest of about four million
households across the United States
working with
regular citizens Farmers factories
working people
fundamentally the Coalition believes
that U.S trade policy has been
imbalanced uh and that and that we
perhaps have uh have tilted toward a
more Global Perspective uh and and not
done enough to protect American jobs
American workers American interests
um and and that is part of the
coalition's it is the Coalition is
composed of both Republicans and
Democrats liberals conservatives it's
it's a a pretty uh interesting stew of
interests but fundamentally on this bill
We Believe that
we made a mistake
several decades ago in sort of creating
this arbitrary Water's Edge provision
that enabled large multinationals to
shift their profits to low tax or even
no tax jurisdictions
and they're really paper transactions
they're not you know it's not really
reflective of the activity that is
happening and so
follow up
thank you on you didn't mention our or
the members businesses or the members
individuals or both
uh we we have both individuals
businesses
um you know workers it it um
it's pretty much every sector every
every industry every um
must have done really well because
there's not that many questions thank
you again let's always do that well we
will see you at the commission thank you
thank you
that is the last pink eye I have for
Testimony we do have a representative
here from the dra if you'd like to just
say anything about this
good morning Representatives my name is
Kean Ming Wong Texas policy Council of
the Department of Revenue Administration
uh the dra does not have a position on
this bill we did prepare a fiscal note
uh be it as it may we were unable to
make any uh substantive calculations on
a fiscal impact
um and I'm here to answer any questions
that the committee may have
um on HP 121 I did also bring a little
um physical quick guide to be
foreign
were passing this around and seeing if
anyone has any quick questions uh do we
yeah it's a little hard to hear you
um maybe could you pass that down for us
just to recap the blue sheet we have two
opposed and one four
uh it looks like a representative from
maybe the Bia yes
uh is
against
sorry I apologize
two people for one person against the
Bia as opposed
and I think you heard from everyone else
okay
representative ulery
yeah
just for the record I'm a little
confused
because corporations are so intertwined
foreign
take for example General Dynamics
corporation which has a major interest
in
Bae UK
but doesn't have an interest in Bae us
which are separate corporations because
of the way that it's set up in um
with the Department of Defense for
defense Industries being U.S
manufacturers even though they may be
owned by a foreign entity I don't know
how that works and I would love to find
out and that would be something that dra
would have insight into
can we ask the ra for some insight into
that
how that gets disentangled or gets
re-entangled or gets messed up
we can certainly ask the dra
um and I would hope that that would be
part of the commission's work that we
could do the Deep dive on that and that
would give them a little bit more time
thank you
so um just to provide a quick
um overview of the um unitary combined
reporting right now currently New
Hampshire is using uh utilizing a
Water's Edge combined reporting whereas
uh all the business entities within a
combined group that are unitary
conducting business unitary will be
reported on one return except for those
that are outside the uh the 50 states
and so in that situation if we do adopt
the worldwide combined unitary reporting
and if the Bae UK is also unitary with
the Bae us then that would be considered
as part of the combined group I think
that would be the the concept behind the
follow-up
yeah I'm just
interested because under DOD regulations
at U.S defense company has to be a U.S
defense company unless stuff is
purchased from I believe that also
applies to a couple other companies in
Southern New Hampshire
um
so are they separate companies
even though they're definitely have an
incestuous relationship
uh but I I don't I'm again this is
something that I'm actually probably
speaking to representing spilsbury on
that I really
would love to know how that's going to
work to to separate that out when you've
got companies that are so closely
intertwined so that extraordinarily
complex was what I heard so I would
encourage all members of this committee
to engage with this commission that we
have already structured even if you're
not appointed to the committee get
involved go to the hearings listen ask
questions be involved as much as you'd
like this is a big question we've been
debating this for 40 years so that's why
we really need to give it the proper
attention before we make a quick
decision
representative plett and then
representative Malloy yes thank you for
taking my question
um the uh this proposal is to go to
worldwide rather than Water's Edge
um what's the other State's practices do
you have does the era have any idea what
the other states do yes um there are
some states that offer worldwide
reporting as an option
so the uh
default would be walrus Edge combined
reporting with the option to elect to do
worldwide and then there are other
states that would say okay yeah that
they would give you they allow a
worldwide reporting but you may elect
um Awards Edge combined reporting
um so different states have um and then
there are some states that just allow
only
thank you for taking my question my
apologies I don't know if I caught the
name of the commission
Madam chairman I can clarify I have it
oh you are you sure
representative has the exact correct
name the commission on worldwide
combined reporting for unitary
businesses under the business profits
tax
and I will do my best if I hear of any
of this and hopefully representative
spilsbury will let the entire committee
know when anything's going on with that
so that we can remain engaged absolutely
uh I will copy the committee uh anytime
okay I guess that's all for oh I'm sorry
one more representative almie
thank you madam chair uh
we have
already been forced to adopt
market-based sourcing which we were told
by dra seems to not be changing our
Revenue picture
on as it has been developed uh
and on the single sales Factor
which
neither we nor dra nor anybody has any
idea what it's going to do to us in 2024
um
and on
this one is also
difficult to figure out is dra going to
continue to try to understand
on the fiscal impact if this was was
developed there are people studying this
uh inside the United States that have
been doing research on this for quite a
while
now currently we do not have a specific
like a task force um in place to do a
specific study on this I think um that
is the purpose of the commission is to
help all to be involved and get a better
understanding of of the fiscal impact or
otherwise other impacts of this bill of
thank you so much for coming today thank
you uh one last check do we have any
more pink cards on House Bill 121
all right seeing none we will close the
public killing hearing
folks we have about 15 minutes before we
reconvene for House Bill 145 so if you
could please be back in your seats by
good morning again
we will now open the public hearing on
House Bill 145
and uh we are looking for any pink cards
see if anyone would like to introduce
let's just give it a moment or two just
in case he's running late and I will see
Madam chairman
representative Spielberg yes if I may I
regarding the last hearing on
representative Schamberg's Bill I just
wanted to point out that everybody has
now received a copy of the commission's
interim report
which reflects the first meeting uh in
October but not the second meeting in
November and pretty much recapitulates
look
representative Army
thank you madam chair this uh bill that
should be before us but isn't uh
impacts your uh directly the decisions
that were made with a great deal of care
two terms ago three terms ago on by the
Attorney General's office and the
current attorney general himself was
very heavily involved as the governor's
lawyer at the time and um
on the Wayfair decision
and on
it I believe that it contradicts the
wayfared decision work but I've just
learned that the Attorney General's
office has
um
lost the person that was overseeing the
actions that would be taken on that if
need came up and that on they have a new
person in charge who
as a sick child and can't appear
yes yes we have requested that the
Eternal generally General's office be
here today for this bill and
unfortunately they cannot uh but they
will send us information by email as
soon as possible on this topic
I have not heard back from the prime
sponsor so I assume I don't care he's
not attending yes representative Ames
remember to put this down uh
I hate to see a bill shelved because
of whatever that we don't know
and I wonder if we could uh
someone on on our committee could
introduce it and uh get it
you know so beyond today so that we
could then hear
from the prime sponsor and the Attorney
General's office is absolutely critical
this is
this is an important subject
um I sense that this is not the bill but
maybe all of us won't agree on that to
address any remaining problems with uh
sales tax collection that really that
derives from the Wayfarer decision but
uh but let's find out and uh maybe we
can continue this proceeding after
getting the bill
built over over the hurdle of being
introduced would you care to do that
introduction for us I'd be happy to do
representative Ames we probably will
have you fill out a ping card at some
point but thank you for introducing
House Bill 145 to the committee I will
fill out a pick card and I I appreciate
the opportunity to introduce House Bill
145 an act relative to a collection of
sales taxes of foreign jurisdictions
by New Hampshire by New Hampshire
businesses uh the prime sponsor
representative Harrington
um is not present and that's why I'm
introducing the bill I uh I'm not
prepared to speak to the bill
all right I see no other pink cards
okay we will now uh we will now
recognize representative pleck yes the
first question what reading this is
whether it was legal or not so listening
to the attorney general to me is
critical that's all
yes I think we all need to have an
update from the AG and hopefully we'll
receive that information soon and we can
kind of go from there but at this time I
think I will close the public hearing on
okay thank you all for coming uh that
reps wraps up our morning we will
reconvene at one o'clock to hear from
the New Hampshire fiscal policy
Institute who would like to give us
their thoughts on the economy so it will
be again a high-level economic briefing
we encourage you to attend that and then
at two o'clock remember we cut short one
of our presenters last week that was the
Department of Unemployment Security and
there was a person who was like a New
Hampshire demographer can't remember
exact title they will be coming back at
two to finish their presentation because
I think there was a lot of questions on
that so I encourage you to stay for that
as well and that will wrap up today's
work uh we are not meeting tomorrow
Wednesday the 18th we will plan on being
here Monday Tuesday and Wednesday next
week
the speaker has mentioned there is a
chance for a house session on Thursday
January 26th but he needs to see what
bills have been exact in committee
before he can tell you for sure
but so that's what we've got right now
so we'll plan next week so Monday the
23rd we're going to start our agency
Revenue estimates
we'll start with dra and then we'll just
keep drilling down and meeting with all
the different agencies Chris Shea has
been totally instrumental on making that
all happen with you know years and years
of Prior experience of running these
things he's setting that all up for so
that will be on Monday the 23rd and on
Friday the 25th
we're going to mix that up a little
excuse me Wednesday the 25th great uh to
mix it up a little bit we will do Bill
hearings on Tuesday the 24th so plan
from 10 to 3 kind of time frame and I
guess I'm looking at right now
to keep going with Bill hearings on
Tuesdays just to keep those moving
forward we still don't have a ton of
bills but we do have to keep marching
forward from what I've seen we don't
have any early deadline bills so those
are the be the bills we have to get done
by mid-February we don't have any yet we
still have until mid-march obviously we
don't want to get too backed up so we'll
keep chipping away at it so the four
bills on the 24th
I might look to representative janigan
and to remind me of the bill numbers
here but they have to do all with some
tax cuts one is a bill on cutting or
eliminating the communication Services
tax there are two having to do with the
IND tax and there's one having to do
with the business Enterprise tax
and he uh representative has the numbers
thank you madam chair so the numbers are
HB 15 is uh cutting the BET tax from
0.55 to 0.5 percent uh HB 100 which is
um
advancing the elimination of the
interest in dividends tax
hb133
which is eliminating the communication
Services tax and HB 192 which proposes
keeping the interest in dividends tax
uh the last one was HP 192.
these will of course all be noticed to
you and in the calendar and I also just
so we cannot finalize our Revenue
estimates until we first see what the
governor comes out with his deadline is
February 15th to come out with his
budget proposal which will include his
Revenue assumptions and so we kind of
need to see what he has before we can
start doing our spreadsheet to monitor
all the different thoughts on this stuff
but what I wanted to get started at
least so you would get at least another
more information on what the agencies do
the type of non-restricted Revenue they
generate and so forth so we'll get that
started next week and then obviously
we'll have to get more detailed
involved in the in the revenue estimates
after the 15th of February so that
following week the week of President's
Day is when we'll have to meet probably
a couple days that week the 21st and the
22nd was what I was thinking uh leaving
Thursdays available for sessions right
now
uh would be my plan so we'll keep
marching away on Bill hearings doing as
much as we can on understanding revenues
and then we'll be formally putting some
thoughts on paper at least starting with
good awesome all right go ahead and take
a break and we'll see you back at one
foreign
okay the the time being 104 I think
um
the um
Phil sletton
research director of the fiscal policy
Institute we'll give a presentation
great great thank you very much for the
opportunity and thank you everyone for
your time this afternoon again I'm Phil
slett and I'm the research director at
the New Hampshire fiscal policy
Institute nhfpi is a non-profit
nonpartisan independent policy research
organization based in Concord we examine
the state budget state revenue policy
and the state economy and the economic
security of granite Staters and I'm
going to try to talk about both of those
areas both state budget and revenue
policy and the state economy in this
presentation
now for this presentation what I'm going
to try to do for the committee is start
big picture with revenues what revenues
look like on sort of a macro scale
narrow down to a couple key Revenue
sources that will be in your interest to
project over the next budget biennium
and then broaden out a little bit with a
wider look at the economy I know you've
spent some time last week and are going
to spend some more time a little bit
this afternoon talking about the economy
in more detail but I want to give you
some big picture pieces and connect them
to State revenues in particular and I
should say at the pleasure of the chair
I'm happy to take questions throughout
the presentation so I'll try to keep my
eyes up periodically and look for hands
especially if you have a particular
question about it that's a technical
question about a slide I'm happy to
field that right away I've also tried to
leave a little bit of time at the end
for broader questions or questions about
topics that I haven't covered in this
presentation
so what about the big picture of State
revenues when we're talking about State
revenues in New Hampshire what are we
talking about broadly and I'm going to
move through these slides relatively
quickly I try to paper clip them for you
together together for you so you could
un undo them and fold them and at least
look at two unfurl them and look at at
least two at a time
so this chart that you see on slide four
is the biggest picture that at least I
can construct of what state revenues
look like at a macro level
um not just including what's in the
state budget not switches including
what's just in some key funds but what
does state revenue look like overall in
terms of what the state collects and
you'll see that federal grants Federal
transfers from the federal government
are a really significant part about 3.7
billion dollars as you can see on that
graph that includes some pandemic
related aid but most of that came in the
last two fiscal years so this is State
fiscal year 2022 you can see federal
grants are a big part of the picture
the next largest slices you can see the
business profits tax is our largest
state tax revenue source and then the
Liquor Commission and the Lottery
Commission and these slices may be
larger than you're sort of used to
seeing used to thinking about when
you're thinking about State revenues
that's because this is measuring gross
revenue and the Liquor Commission and
Lottery Commission have to pay for their
own expenses running the stores
purchasing the products uh paying for
winnings Etc and then after that the
meals and rentals tax Statewide
education property tax business
Enterprise tax Medicaid enhancement tax
real estate transfer tax and the list
goes on to some of the smaller tax
revenue sources there
um so that's sort of the large picture
and uh and I want to talk a moment about
that Federal fund slice because federal
funds have been a really significant
part of both state revenues funding
State services or services that are
provided by the state and the state
economy particularly over the last two
years they are every year but
particularly over the last two years
they've been significant as you can see
on Slide Five this is the total amount
of Revenue that has come from the
federal government to the state over the
year and a quarter roughly from March of
2020 related to covid-19
pandemic relief packages and Recovery
packages
and that 17 billion dollar figure I do
uh last budget that's a good question so
because not all federal funds or state
funds go through the state budget the
portion that's federal grants associated
with state budget is about the same size
um but uh the amount of so if you were
to take the pie chart the same pie chart
that you see on slide four for uh fiscal
year uh 2021 then you'd see that it's
almost half of the pie so it's dropped
significantly between 2021 and 2022. and
I'm I'm sorry uh chair I want to go to
you first to call on members so my
apologies for that that's that's okay
we'll do that from now on okay my
apologies I was eager to answer the
question so my apologies to uh for
jumping in
um so if the you can see in this pie
chart
um 17 billion dollars roughly is the
number and it's this pie chart as as of
July 2022 as of the end of September
um that figure was about the same and
these numbers are from the office of
legislative budget assistant which
tracks these revenues as they come to
the state and I should note this is not
just the state government this is you
know you could see the largest slice of
the pie is a paycheck Protection Program
and other Aid to businesses about five
billion dollars so that's going into the
economy
um economic impact payments to
individuals the so-called stimulus
checks right that's the next largest
slice but one of the significant
components here is that 17 billion
dollars that's larger than a two-year
state budget right which is about 13.6
billion dollars so when we're talking
about money flowing into state
government and the state economy and
local governments and other entities in
the state this is a really significant
infusion of resources that we've just
seen not all of this has been spent yet
but that we've just seen over the last
uh two and a half years or so
and relative to the size of the state
economy which as you can see on the
slide in 2019 was about 87 billion
dollars our growth State product if you
will our state version of gross domestic
product
17 billion dollars is a really
significant bump in resources
um relative to pre-pandemic economy and
relative to what usual state
expenditures are if you will
so let's talk about the tax revenue
sources a little bit more that was the
uh the big picture of federal grants
related to covid-19 what about tax
revenue sources this pie chart looks at
sort of the big picture of state and
local tax revenue sources combined and
here you can see and this is on slide
six so my apologies for those of you
that are leafing through
um for moving too quickly but uh on
slide six you can see state and local
tax revenue sources combined
and you'll note that the local property
tax is a little bit more than half of
all the state and local taxes collected
in New Hampshire
the Statewide education property tax
which is raised and retained locally is
another five percent on top of that that
functions more effectively like a local
property tax and then you could see in
Orange the business profits and business
Enterprise taxes together and then the
smaller tax revenue sources all the way
down to the interest in dividends tax
other state taxes and other local taxes
there are some other local tax revenue
sources but they're relatively small
compared to the property tax include
things like the timber tax the
excavation tax Etc
so on slide 7 you'll see what may be a
more familiar array of revenues and
their relative size when you as the
house Ways and Means Committee are
thinking about projecting revenues and
that's because these are the revenues to
the general fund and the education trust
fund combined and a lot of these Revenue
sources are shared for example you can
see the business profits and business
Enterprise tax the taxes which I've
shaded together here both of them are
split between the general fund and the
education trust fund they have their own
unique splits across the two different
tax revenue sources this uh you could
see that it's about it's more than a
third of Revenue to the general
education trust funds or from the two
business taxes combined and I've shaded
them together because
it's difficult to tell exactly what is
business profits tax revenue what is
business Enterprise tax revenue until
all the returns are in and all the
information has been sorted by the
Department of Revenue Administration
there's sometimes a significant lag
there so the split you see here is what
the annual comprehensive financial
report uh shows for a fiscal year but
that can include uh revenue from many
different tax years and is not
necessarily uh in line with exactly what
is the split between the business
profits and business Enterprise taxes
excuse me we have a question
representative play yes thank you you're
going kind of fast uh the the revenues
you touched on earlier combined 17
billion this shot shows a revenues of
general and education is that still 17
billion or is it a bigger pie no this is
yes that's a great question
um the 17 billion is the federal revenue
the revenue that comes from the federal
government and has come but with
covid-19 related Aid so that's that's
talking about that sort of federal fund
slice of the pie so back to on on slide
four and you can see it on the screen I
talked about the federal revenue piece
and particularly the covid-19 related so
that Federal size slice and then the
rest of the revenue sources broken down
by tax revenue on slide six slide seven
is a subset of that slide six those tax
revenue sources and some of the other
Revenue sources that you saw in slide
four so slide seven
um we were talking about General and
education trust fund revenues bigger
Tech now what's the number yes so the
number in total on slide 10 you can see
is a little bit is about 3.2 billion I
believe was the number I think it's like
3.424 billion is what it is
um so that General and education trust
funds piece is just the subset of for
example the whole state budget on slide
eight you can see the breakdown of what
is in the state budget by fund and sorry
to skip around a little bit here but
this question covers a fair bit of
ground
slide 8 shows the general fund and the
education trust fund combined that's
about 40 percent of the state budget and
the state budget in state fiscal year
2022 appropriated a little bit north of
six billion dollars
um so that's what was appropriated not
the revenue collected the revenue
collected ended up being a little bit
north of 3 billion uh again 3.2 billion
dollars I believe it was so that was a
lot of information right there I'm happy
to answer a follow-up question if I can
help provide clarity
representative Ami
thank you on are fees in other funds on
slide eight uh on slide eight uh well
yes
um that's not to say that there aren't
fees that don't go to the general fund
there are some uh that end up in the
general fund but other funds would be
specific dedicated funds for oftentimes
for specific purposes for example the
food protection section collects fees
associated with doing food inspections
at restaurants and a portion of those
fees go to a specific fund that helps
support the food protection section
that's an example of something that
would end up in the other funds category
so it's I believe the last uh time I
heard a reference to is more than 200
other funds special dedicated funds for
thank you yep I think they're more than
that there may be more than that the
number I've heard is more than 200 but I
wouldn't be surprised if it's above
three at this point
representative ours
thank you Mr chairman and thanks for
taking my question so if I don't I don't
want to have to do the math but for
state tax and other revenues is that
about 13 billion or can you give us the
number so we don't have to add all these
up yeah so the state tax and other
revenues I believe uh the total on that
and I can get back to you with the
number but the total is a little north
of 9 billion
um is what it is um and again that's
including revenues beyond what you see
in the state budget for example
um and this is including all
governmental and Enterprise funds so not
all this Revenue shows up in the state
budget which is why that number is
different than the six billion dollars
in change you see annually in the in the
state budget Appropriations but this is
the as I as I noted this is my attempt
to get as comprehensively as I can to
all the revenue sources that the state
has based on the annual comprehensive
financial report
okay thank you and a follow-up question
if I may follow up
page number six what is the number for
that
uh yes so the number for this
um
I don't remember off the top of my head
what this number is
um but I can get back to you with that
total if you'd like okay thank you very
much you're welcome
I I should note you know that the uh
state tax revenue sources and I'll get
back to you with a specific number I
want to make sure I have the the correct
one
okay
continue yes
so
um if we look at so again on slide eight
um the general education trust funds
which is
um which are the revenues for that are
represented on slide seven
um and you can see it's actually one
thing I want to note on slide seven it's
a relatively diverse picture right
there's other than the business profits
tax growing to be us uh more than a
quarter of the whole pie chart otherwise
other than the business profits tax
business Enterprise tax on the Statewide
education property tax everything else
is under 10 with the meals and rentals
tax starting to get to that 10 figure so
it means it's a relatively diverse tax
revenue base for the general and
education trust funds
and on slide eight uh you can see how
the state budget is broken down and
again not all tax rate not all revenue
that the state collects including those
federal grants go through the state
budget itself but the state budget has
about a third funded through Federal
transfers and 40 percent come from those
so I'll move us on to if we're if we're
ready I'll move us on to revenue Trends
since the pandemic and really some
recent Revenue Trends and this was the
slide I referred to earlier this is
slide 10. this shows the
inflation-adjusted revenue over time to
the general and education trust funds
and this is irrespective of policy
changes so there are changes in tax
rates there are changes in which funds
are in the general fund or in the
education trust funds and which aren't
over the course of this time period
because it's going back to 2006 but you
can see it's been a relatively steady
picture that being said before the Great
Recession we saw higher Revenue so 2006
2007 2008 and then there was a very long
period in which the revenues were
substantially below that in
inflation-adjusted terms until about
2015 2016 we saw the economy after a
slow a period of very slow growth start
to pick up again and that was reflected
in tax revenues and then most recently
we saw a decline in state fiscal year
2020 associated with the pandemic and
then we see these increases in 2021 and
2022 which we'll talk about a little bit
more
so those increases and on slide 11 you
can see an array of Revenue sources for
the general and education trust funds
what has been driving some of those
increases well in dollar terms we can
see that the combined business taxes
have been the primary driver you can see
shaded in green is State fiscal year is
2017 to 2022 what the difference is and
then shaded in blue a little shorter
timeline State fiscal year 2019 so just
before the pandemic to State fiscal year
2022 and you can see the business taxes
combined even between 2019 and 2022 have
added essentially more than a whole
meals and rentals tax in additional
Revenue over that time period that being
said the real estate transfer tax the
meals and rentals tax and the interest
in dividends tax as well as Lottery
Commission revenues have done relatively
well over this time period too the
tobacco tax I wouldn't expect to be a
growing tax revenue Source going into
the future for some of the reasons
commissioner step already spoke about
last week but it's probably going to to
be a declining Revenue Source over time
and because it is a fixed dollar amount
for packs of cigarettes it's a declining
source of real Revenue as well after you
adjust for inflation
insurance premium tax revenues have done
relatively well Liquor Commission
revenues if you compare these uh these
two periods have been relatively flat
that being said there are Liquor
Commission revenues that go to other
operations outside of the general fund
that go to other funds such as the
alcohol abuse prevention treatment fund
so some of those policy changes in that
window have likely affected that number
and then you can see all other General
and education trust fund revenues second
to the right those have actually been
down over this time period so if you
look at all the other Revenue sources
combined we see a net reduction in uh in
revenues and again these are not
adjusted for inflation so this is a
nominal dollar figures if you will so
the shows that the revenue drivers the
primary revenue drivers are covered in
these other tax revenue sources or other
Revenue sources I should say
and uh all the way over on the right I
put the motor fuels tax in as well this
does not support the general and
education trust funds but it does
support the highway fund so something
that uh this committee will likely be
thinking about and those revenues are
still a little bit down in 2022 relative
to where they were in 17 and 19.
so if you prefer lines to bars then and
you want to see on a monthly basis this
is the slide 12 is a 12 month rolling
average that shows what the change in
Revenue in dollars has been relative to
the prior year going back to 2014 state
fiscal year 2014. you could see that
thick green line is general and
education trust funds Revenue The Thin
Blue Line the thinner blue line is
without the business profits and
business Enterprise taxes backing those
out and then uh um the business
Enterprise business profits meals and
rentals and real estate transfer taxes
are backed out in that thin orange line
and there's a couple you know noteworthy
deviations from that from uh Trend if
you will um over over the course of this
time period one is that first rise that
we see which is broadly across tax
revenue sources that's really the
economy starting to pick up again after
the Great Recession the second one you
can see is almost entirely that green
one line that's business tax revenue
increasing after the tax cuts and jobs
act at the federal level spurred more
repatriation and actual repatriation as
opposed to deemed repatriation of um of
corporate profits that were captured in
the business profits tax revenues we see
a drop following those one-time revenues
and associated with the beginning of the
pandemic and then a really significant
increase particularly in the business
taxes so that green lines pushed up
further but also in other tax revenue
sources to the general and education
trust funds because you can see that
that orange line and the blue line are
also historically relatively High
so let's talk about the tax revenue
sources in a little bit more detail I'm
not going to go Source by Source but I'm
going to go to a few specific sources
yes was there a question
does anyone have any questions on that
last section or we all sent
okay yes okay great thank you very much
so the two primary business taxes just
to
um uh review some of the some of the
material that you've already seen the
business profits tax is uh is more like
your typical State corporate income tax
it's based on Gross business profits and
corporate income there are adjustments
including credits for business
Enterprise tax paid that's applied to
the business profits tax and
apportionment which apportionment is the
process for determining how much tax uh
Revenue a multi-state entity owes to the
state of New Hampshire
the tax base for this so the pool of
economic activity that this is drawing
from was likely about 6.8 billion
dollars in tax year 2020. and again tax
year 2020 is the most recent year for
which we have the sort of the final or
close to final parsing between the
business profits and the business
Enterprise taxes um so that's yeah
um so where it says tax based on Gross
business profits
um that is the threshold I believe as to
whether the tax whether you're possibly
subject to the tax but the tax itself is
based on the net business profits is it
not uh so thinking back to the statute
um the uh there are ways that you can
apply credits and there are ways that
you could apply sort of for example that
initial exemption
um whether that uh so when I say tax
based on Gross business profits here
that's part of the calculation right
that's the first of the string of
calculations that's done here because
there's those gross business profits and
there are adjustments for it adjustments
is made and then apportionment so I hope
that answered your question
okay so yeah I just wanted to make clear
that the actual tax you pay is based on
the gross minus those adjustments minus
the businesses expenses and then right
yeah so there so there are
um there are adjustments and I did use
the term profits as opposed to income
there you know so with some intention
around that too thank you yep absolutely
um so the tax rate is then applied to
that roughly 6.8 billion dollars
um that was the tax base and there have
been a series of rate reductions so from
2001 to 2015 it was eight and a half
percent
um in tax year 2023 seven and a half
percent over because of those rate
reductions over this time period and
again supports the general and education
trust funds the business Enterprise tax
is actually a little bit it's Unique
among state tax revenue sources
um and among business taxes that other
states have it's based on compensation
or interest paid or accrued and
dividends paid as well as adjustments
and apportionment so again working down
from that larger base and and making
those adjust based on credits and other
and other other things that are not
included in the tax base that tax base
because compensation is in it is much
broader it was likely about 36 billion
dollars in tax year 2020. so much
broader than than that business profits
tax base there have been a series of
rate reductions uh that you'll note that
the rate itself can be much lower
because that base is much broader to
collect a significant amount of Revenue
it's gone from in 2015 three-quarters of
a percent to 0.55 percent starting in
2022 and supports the education trust
fund and the general fund
so on slide 15 what you'll see and
you'll see a series of graphs that are
like this
you'll see the inflation adjusted tax
revenue and the uh the percentage growth
based on those inflation adjustments and
um so after those inflation adjustments
this is what the percentage of sort of
real inflation-adjusted tax revenue
growth was
part of the reason why I want to break
that down for you here is because as a
committee when you're thinking about
Revenue projections you may want to
think about what is the actual growth or
change in the underlying economic
activity and what is inflation going to
be because that affects how many dollars
will be collected through those tax
revenue sources right so there are two
components not just what the economic
growth is but also what is the what is
what do you expect inflation to be and
how might that affect what those actual
numbers end up being in terms of your
final projections so this graph shows
what again adjusted for inflation the
Consumer Price Index for urban consumers
in the Northeast
what the actual underlying growth may
have been in the tax base right based on
the tax returns that we have
and you can see here and again we have
the estimate between the business
profits and the business Enterprise tax
but the total tax amount is what matters
most here
um I don't even I'll say that
um uh I'll say that we'll talk in the
next slide a little bit more about the
split between the two but uh there was
growth prior to the Great Recession
after the Great Recession there was a
long period of time with very little
business tax growth in terms of business
tax revenues and then we saw when the
economy started to pick up again in 2014
and 2015 that being captured in state
fiscal year 2016 revenues and going
forward there was a drop in 2020 and
then really significant even after
adjusting for inflation really
significant increases in fiscal 21 and
22. so before we talk about those
increases I do want to mention something
oh yes I do have a question
representative army yes on
can you
explain
that such a increase in 2016.
and then a decrease
and then another increase
and we seem to be wavering back and
forth a lot more than we used to yes so
in 2016 I would attribute most of that
to what we saw in the earlier slide that
showed the 12-month rolling averages I
would attribute most of that to uh
Revenue growth that came from the
economy speeding up particularly in 2014
and 2015 if you look at New Hampshire
Gross State product you see there was a
period of very low growth from about
2010 2009 2010 and the negative growth
that we saw or the the reduction the
size of the economy going from the Great
Recession for those next few years and
then we see that grow State product
growth start to pick up again in 2014
and 2015. that starts to be captured I
believe in those State fiscal year 2016
revenues both probably the early some of
the estimate payments that were earlier
on and some of the tax returns that we
saw filed in 2016 that you know may have
been a adjusting for estimates from the
first half for the second half of State
fiscal year 2015. that was adjusting
from those quarterly estimate payments
so that's I think 2016 is mostly
explained by the economy 2017 it could
be that we saw you know I I'm trying to
remember what the specific growth State
product number was but we probably saw
maybe a similar amount of growth but we
did see tax rates start to be reduced
also during that time period so that
could have had some effect
that's where we start capturing the
one-time revenues associated with the
tax cuts and jobs act and I think that
bumped for 2018 and part of State fiscal
year 2019 those revenues in a
substantial Way Beyond what we saw in
terms of economic activity so those
would be my my guesses as the primary
sources but of course the the individual
tax returns which I don't see are are
the ones that would tell the story in a
clearer picture
thank you yep you're welcome
okay great
um so on slide 16 one thing I do want to
highlight and this is something
commissioner step mentioned last week is
the split between the business profits
and the business Enterprise taxes and
these are using those um close to final
tax year data that splits between the
two Revenue sources
um you'll see in your daily revenue
reports you'll see in the monthly
Revenue Focus the split between the
business profits and the business
Enterprise tax estimated but in the
actual estimated payments the Department
of Revenue Administration doesn't have
that information in detail so I will say
as someone who also reads those monthly
revenue reports and looks at daily
revenue updates I don't pay very much
attention at all to the split between
the business profits and the business
Enterprise tax on those shorter term
pieces because a lot of the a lot of the
estimated or a lot of the split is based
on historical estimates of 60 business
profits tax 40 percent is business
Enterprise tax and you can see that
especially between about 2009 and maybe
even 2016 that that has been what the
split has been in a relatively stable
pattern but since then we've seen the
business profits taxes become more
important as a state tax revenue Source
relative to the business Enterprise tax
and the most recent years it's more like
a 70 30 split so so that is I think a
significant change when you're thinking
about what are the impacts of various
economic factors on state revenues going
forward is that the business profits tax
is becoming more important so that tax
base is going to be more significant in
your in your thoughts and your
projections
okay we have a couple of questions uh
representative Platt thank you thank you
for taking my question back on slide 12
how do you explain the pump in 2020
uh the bump in 2020 yes so um so
actually we're just getting to that um
so I'm happy to so you're talking about
the bump that's uh since 2020 are you
talking about the like the most recent
rise I've been 2022. see the big bump
yes
um so I'm I'm uh I've got a couple
slides that I think will help address
that but the upshot is uh corporate
profits have done quite well and as you
saw that that business profits tax is
becoming more important I think that's a
representative Ami
thank you and you didn't mention but I
think it's true that about 80 percent of
the business Enterprise tax is
um
payroll
yeah and so it's jobs yes compensation
is a really big part right of the of the
business Enterprise tax base which is
why it's much broader yes than the
business profits tax and I'm not sure if
it was clear that on since the business
Enterprise tax is a credit on the
business profits tax if we took away the
business Enterprise tax and nothing
changed because of that we would have uh
companies paying the same thing they'd
been paying before in business profits
Tax Plus business Enterprise tax so uh
four companies that have a taxable
profit under the business profits tax
and also pay business Enterprise tax
there is a one for one credit right one
dollar for one dollar so you those
companies will uh if you this is
referring to it colloquially but will
pay business Enterprise fed tax first
and then apply that tax credit to the
business profit tax
and when we talk about the tax basis for
these two tax revenue sources you'll see
that the as a result the business
profits tax base is much narrower
um that and that business Enterprise tax
credit is likely a significant part of
that
any other questions
okay and these questions are very
apropos because the first pie chart that
I was going to show you in this series
of pie charts here is uh the relative
size of entities that are paying
business profits tax and business
Enterprise tax
um the business pro this is looking at
just the business profits tax base you
can see that 78 filers so 78 business
entities or combined reporting entities
paid about 38 percent of the business
profits tax and then another 644 filers
paid almost the same amount of money
again so relative to the uh roughly 77
000 filers I believe it was that filed
in tax year 2020.
um this uh the largest entities or the
entities with the largest profits are
disproportionately important in the
business profits tax base
representative Platt yeah I have trouble
when information is missing the 78
filers how big are they there's no size
listed on this chart to be as opposed to
the rest yeah so the this is all
information from the Department of
Revenue administration's annual reports
so those are available in those inverted
triangles that I believe have been
referred to before by that committee
um the 78 filers uh if I recall
correctly from tax year 2019 I believe
the average size in terms of the profits
that they reported uh was about and this
is reported profits so this isn't the
size of the the business operation but
this is reported profits I believe it
was about
um
35 or 40 million dollars but I will get
you that I will send you the link
specifically to that page on the page
representative Amy if I could when the
dra comes back I expect them to come
with the triangles
and they I I do I do think they're more
easy to follow yeah the the triangles
are
um uh the the triangles are published
already in the annual report so I'm
happy to provide you with uh with that
ahead of time
um and yes what you'll see here is that
I've broken out parts of the triangles
into a series of pie charts to try and
break it apart for folks to see visually
but it does depend on what your
preference is whether you prefer to see
it in a table or a pie chart so uh in
some ways it's easier to consume
um and to consume the information the
triangle but it's harder to see and on
victories must be within some kind of
range and so the the Big Orange range is
whatever is the highest amount of tax
that was paid in and
yes these are based on what the
Department of Revenue Administration
reports in those inverted triangles
based on categories of taxes paid right
so
um that largest one I'm trying to
remember I it's more than it's more than
a certain amount of tax revenue paid and
I don't remember exactly what that
threshold is but again I can provide it
to the committee
mm-hmm
representative Schamberg thank you Mr
chairman just a question
you said that
if they pay the BET tax first
they then use that one-to-one to reduce
their BPT correct
if the rate of the bet is reduced does
that mean there will be more BPT to be
paid by the companies yes I just want to
make sure I figured that out right yes
and indeed in the initial proposal of
the um from the governor's budget from
2021 there was a bet reduction and not a
BPT reduction and in the analysis
provided by the Department of Revenue
Administration you saw business
Enterprise tax revenues go down and then
some Revenue was recaptured by the
business profits tax it wasn't all of it
because not every company is paying
business profits tax but the ones that
were then had a smaller credit a smaller
business Enterprise tax credit and were
expected then to then pay business
okay great
um so another way that we can learn
about the business profits tax base is
by file or type
um I I believe you spent some time this
morning talking about uh Waters Edge
combined reporting entities so you can
see here this is the breakdown and this
is again from the Department of Revenue
Administration you can see the breakdown
by file or type so Proprietors including
sole Proprietors are roughly 39
corporations 35 percent Partnerships
fiduciaries and then the water's edge
filers that you can see in Orange here
those are what I called here
multinational combined entities
basically and I'm glossing over a lot of
details here but basically that means
that's a multi-part business filer with
at least one part of that entity
combined reporting entity that has a
significant amount of its operations
overseas right so there's at least one
component of a multi-part business that
is overseas that's not to say that the
corporations and the other entities on
here aren't operating overseas and
that's also not to say that the water's
edge filers are only operating overseas
they often and probably do have a
significant amount of property personnel
and and sales in New Hampshire but they
are at least a large multi-part entity
that has a significant part of at least
one of their operations in a different
country so that gives us some sense some
understanding of what these what these
businesses might look like
so on slide 18 you can see about six
percent of filers were combined
reporting entities on slide 19 you can
see if you break it down by Revenue more
than half the revenue came from Water's
Edge filers so again what that means is
when we're thinking about Revenue
projections we may also have to think
about the global economy we may have to
think about National corporate profits
as well because these are multi-state
multinational entities that are
important part of the business profits
tax base
if we compare that to the business
Enterprise tax base we can see and this
is the the same pie chart that you saw
first but for the business Enterprise
tax it's a much broader tax base right
in part because of that business
Enterprise tax credit that's used
against the business profits tax you can
see the top 12 filers paid 23.5 million
dollars a much smaller share than we see
for the business profits tax for example
that being said uh on slide 21 even
though we have a much broader business
Enterprise tax base uh the water's edge
filers are still a significant portion
of the amount of business Enterprise tax
revenue paid so again still an important
component of the tax base when you're
thinking about what's going to happen
with business tax revenues
and on slide 22 I think this is a key
part of why we've seen that increase in
state fiscal years 2021 and 22 in terms
of tax revenues uh in the business taxes
we see that there was a dip in the
second quarter of 2020 that's associated
with the pandemic but this graph goes
from 2017 all the way to the second
third quarter of 2022 and we can see
that on an annualized basis so this is
not quarterly but if it's if we took the
profits in this quarter and annualize
them that U.S corporate profits
adjusting again for inventory and for
Capital consumption have gone from a
little more than two trillion dollars a
year to about three trillion dollars a
year so that's a really significant
increase that part of that is likely
being caught in the business profits tax
base in New Hampshire and that as I
think if I were to point to one reason
that is I think the key reason why we've
seen business tax revenues go up writ
large because of the because of this
increase
if we look at slide 23 this is the
business Enterprise tax and again broken
out only to tax year 2020 because that's
when we have the final breakouts there
are three lines on this graph you can
see business Enterprise tax revenue in
green new hampshire-based private sector
employment because as representative
valmie pointed out employment is a big
part of the tax base here you can see
that employment in blue and wages paid
in New Hampshire in Orange and you can
see that the business Enterprise tax
revenue actually follows the wages paid
the total amount of dollars a wages paid
a little bit more closely than it
follows that private sector employment
you can see there are deviations from
the trend in 2016 2018 2019 and those
were years in which there was a tax rate
reduction to the business Enterprise tax
so that we see that that Revenue may not
have trended as it would have otherwise
and then of course 2020 was a pandemic
year in terms of tax year 2020. um that
being said wages pays still went up it
could be that some businesses were for
example using their credit carry forward
for tax year 2020 and may have resulted
in less Revenue in that year under the
business Enterprise tax and a number of
other factors could have applied
and I'll uh quickly mention that as
important as as we've talked about these
business pro the business profits and
the business Enterprise tax revenue
being to state revenue the Council on
state estate taxation looks at number of
dollars paid by businesses in New
Hampshire in the state and local taxes
and the BPT and the bet combiner about a
quarter about half are property taxes so
and that's been a relatively consistent
number over the years so that's again
when we're thinking about what our taxes
businesses paying in the state property
taxes are an important part of the
picture and that includes of course the
local property tax
all right if we're ready I'll move on to
meals and rentals tax does anybody have
any questions on the the business taxes
representative spilsbury yes taking the
last several uh slides together
we don't have a presentation that makes
these same breakouts over a span of
several years so so we've seen the
Aggregates uh as they changed from 2008
on uh
would it be accurate that
simultaneous with the three years of
aggressive growth in BPT revenues
there's also been a shift in the mix
increasingly towards
a corporate structures B large corporate
structures see multinational sort of in
that progression is that likely so I can
say that at least between tax year 2019
and tax year 2020 those top it was 80
filers in 2019 78 and 2020 that dropped
from about 44 to 38 percent but tax year
2020 was also a unique year because of
the pandemic so I would have to look
back and be able to say definitively has
that Trend in larger corporate profits
been driving the driving factor in the
BPT becoming more important I wonder if
you could generate a slide for us that
would track the shift in the mix over
say a 10-year span
uh I think the dra's annual reports
would allow me to do all 10 years so I
all right if we're okay I think we're
all set move forward okay and I'll try
to move through these quickly I
recognize I only have about 13 minutes
left and I have a fair number of slides
beyond that
um so I will do my best to move quickly
through here uh meals and rentals tax
eight and a half percent tax that's
largely driven by meals at restaurants
but also hotel rooms and rental cars
um the revenue has been split up in the
most recent year to the municipal
Revenue fund um the meals and rooms
Municipal Revenue fund I believe it's
called you can see that transfer on that
rightmost bar I've included it here
because it's part of the revenue
collected and something that you may
want to think about when you're thinking
about projecting Revenue again these are
inflation adjusted changes over time I
want to draw your attention to 2014 to
2019 where the meals and rentals tax was
sort of a Workhorse Revenue Source in
that it consistently outpaced inflation
grew faster than inflation when the
economy was expanding during that time
period obviously the pandemic had a
pretty big impact on it but it has
rebounded some since then if we look at
slide 27 yes if I may I have a question
on that so yes you're showing on 2022
the municipal Revenue fund transfer it
did increase for that year but that
shouldn't that apply to every year uh so
that's a great question the municipal
Revenue so a portion of the meals and
rentals tax has been devoted to
Municipal Revenue sharing over this
entire time Horizon that you see on this
graph previously it was funneled through
the general fund so you would see that
Revenue when you were for example
projecting general fund revenue for from
a general and education trust fund
revenue from the meals and rentals tax
that has been moved off budget entirely
so it no longer goes to the general fund
as a result there's this separate
transfer to track revenues this is a
separate transfer to the rooms and meals
or meals and rooms pardon me Municipal
Revenue fund okay thank you that's a
good distinction yes you're welcome
because the rest of the green bars are
for General and education trust fund
Revenue so previous previously it would
have covered it but now things are a
we have another question representative
fellows yeah was that what you were just
talking about was that just like a
one-year deal or is that fairly
permanent yeah under current statute
that is permanent so that was a change
in the in what is the current state
budget to instead of having those funds
go through the general fund that what is
uh about I think 100.1 million dollars
doesn't show up in the general fund
anymore it goes right to this other fund
and if I remember correctly there was a
there were two changes there was a
change in the amount from about 22
percent to roughly 30 percent and now
the added distinction is that it's now
going
um
directly to municipalities yes so so to
build on that there used to be there was
originally a set in statute was 40 but
the uh state had not been meeting that
40 obligation uh and as a result there
was a catch-up formula to catch up
slowly to that 40 level sometimes that
ketchup formula had been suspended as a
result uh about 22 percent was uh where
it ended up more recently it was hovered
between 19 and about about 20 so
um that 22 was then boosted to 30
percent by a change in statute got rid
of the ketchup formula boosted it to 30
and moved it to the separate fund
exactly thank you for clarifying
representative Almighty
thank you and this and a number of other
things in our revenues are a result of
the finance committee paying no
attention to our need to be able to
track revenues
as far as I'm concerned on and on
we
we compensate we compensate for them uh
like this for a couple of years and then
get used to the new trend and kind of
forget about it but there have been
times when I think they took the entire
department of labor into a dedicated
fund one term so that they could pretend
they hadn't raised the spending and then
any other questions
okay
great and again I'll uh recognizing it's
151 I'll try to move through these
quickly
um meals and rentals tax revenues in
some ways do track accommodation food
services employment this is on a cash
basis on slide 27 a rolling monthly Cash
basis with a 12-month rolling average so
that there's not the seasonal effects I
think a significant part of what we're
seeing in the recent rise in meals and
rentals tax revenue which is sort of
back up to trend is because and you can
see on the orange line on this graph an
increase in costs associated with food
away from home right this is the
inflation measure for what is a food
what is food at a restaurant cost and
that has increased more rapidly and that
of course is going to be going to show
up in meals and rentals tax revenue as
well so that's where again the inflation
in these costs I think going to be an
important factor when you're thinking
about what are revenues going to look
like going forward
representative Platt I'm having trouble
understanding this graphic as you say
momentum slowing but other than the
pandemic dip looks like it's right back
before pandemic and higher so where is
it slowing so I think that I think
that's where the trend line right if
we're back at trend line now we
shouldn't necessarily expect the same
year-over-year growth we've seen over
the last two years right since the
depths of the pandemic so that's where I
think that momentum is slowing also if
we were talking about nominal dollars
right unadjusted for inflation if
inflation eases in food away from home
then we'll see Revenue growth that
okay
okay great
um real estate transfer tax is and I'll
go to slide 29 here it's another example
of where there is a small portion that's
been uh set aside for a dedicated fund
um that's that five million dollar
transfer to the affordable housing fund
if we look at real estate transfer tax
revenues over time you can see that it
again adjusted for inflation we're about
now and maybe a little bit higher than
the um pre-great recession uh growth
that we saw in housing that peaked in
about 2005 before it started to slip
associated with the Great Recession and
was much lower this was a growing
Revenue Source prior to the pandemic
although this is a supply limited
Revenue source and if we look at slide
30 you can see that Supply limitation
has become much more acute over time
this slide 30 shows in the dashed lines
two measures of inventory for
single-family homes and condos and that
months of inventory was down to one to
one a half months maybe it's easing a
little bit more recently the my
understanding is that oftentimes a
balanced Supply is considered six or six
and a half months that isn't even on
this graph so we had a constrained
housing Supply before the pandemic you
can see in that middle period with this
12-month rolling average that inventory
really dropped and prices started to
increase dramatically so between March
2017 and March 2022 the median single
family home price in New Hampshire was
up 80 percent right and what that means
is that we saw growth in real estate
transfer tax revenues as you can see on
slide 31 again 12-month rolling average
but we see total sales volume which is
in green in the triangles that that
total sales volume has been leveling off
real estate transfer tax revenues have
edged up a little bit further and
remember of course commercial property
and other properties in the real estate
transfer tax base as well but maybe
we're seeing that real estate transfer
tax start to level off to because of
slower sales
part of the reason we see slower sales
because the real estate transfer tax of
course depending on the number of sales
as well as the price
um we've seen as you can see on slide 32
perhaps the median uh home sale price at
least approached a regional Peak
Statewide around May or June and since
then has been dropping of course condo
prices appear to still be increasing but
you can see in the dashed line is
mortgage interest rates average mortgage
interest rates for a 30-year fixed loan
that means that housing has become more
expensive for people who need to take
out a loan to buy a house that higher
interest rate means it's functionally
more expensive that doesn't show up in
our real estate transfer tax revenues
because that's dependent on the sale
price not dependent on what people are
paying in their mortgage monthly
mortgage payment for example so that may
affect real estate transfer tax revenues
at the same time leading up to the
pandemic a lot of us were expecting that
Supply would constrain real estate
transfer tax revenues it may have some
but the revenues continue to grow so
there is still quite a bit of housing
demand as you can see on slide 33 there
are probably quite a few people who are
in the rental market who otherwise would
prefer to buy a home and as a result
we're seeing rental vacancy rates
dropping substantially and rents rising
and with those rental costs Rising that
means that that there are people who are
renting who would otherwise have
purchased a home already if they could
afford it I can't quantify that for you
but it does mean that lower income
renters for example the 36 percent of
renters who had less than thirty five
thousand dollars per year in income are
paying a larger and larger share of
their income in rent so as you can see
on the pie chart about three quarters of
renters who have less than thirty five
thousand dollars per year in income in
New Hampshire in the 2017 to 2021 period
owed uh 30 or more of their income in
rent so there's likely a fair bit of
housing demand still out there part of
the question is is it accessible because
of the prices
and that's something to think about when
thinking about real estate transfer tax
revenues going forward and we're talking
about me median incomes for renters
they're much lower than median incomes
for people who own their homes
so interest in dividends tax really
quickly
um a five percent tax on interest
dividend and distribution income from
assets this is income generated from
wealth particularly from stock ownership
or ownership and businesses or from
interest on you know bank accounts for
example
under current law this is to be phased
out starting for tax year 2023 so the
taxes that will be filed in final form
in the spring of 2024 you can see that
this moves with the economy some and
actually there's been a pretty
significant increase in 2022 which
boosted this up in terms of where it is
relative to other General and education
trust fund Revenue sources when thinking
about this Revenue source and you can
see in this in the chart on slide 37
which is closer to what you find in the
dras 20 annual report this this provides
a little more detail
when we're thinking about where revenues
for this may Trend it's important to
think about those asset values what
income is generated from assets
particularly for people with high
incomes because about two and a half
percent of filers paid more than half of
the total collection of interest and
dividends tax revenue and that's uh
those are filers who had whether
individual or joint filers who had more
than two hundred thousand dollars a year
in taxable interest in dividends tax
revenue so what happens with those
higher income higher asset value filers
will be important when we're projecting
interest in dividends tax revenues
so I'll mention a couple things getting
to the economic Outlook portion of the
presentation and I'm watching the clock
as well and seeing
um I want to make sure that I'm not
stepping on the next guests so I I don't
see them here yet but I will I will go
as long as you'd like me to if that uh
if you'd like
um the um the on slide 39 we can see
that this recovery has been much faster
than the last economic recovery from the
Great Recession this is something that
director gotlab and this is the Deputy
Commissioner lavers talked about last
week using um uh the labor force and
employment this is looking at median
household income inflation-adjusted
median household income in New Hampshire
and you can see that from its peak in
2007 prior to the Great Recession it
took about eight to ten years to get
back to those inflation-adjusted uh
levels in terms of what the purchasing
power the median household was we don't
have data for 2020 unfortunately because
of complications with the pandemic but
between 2019 and 2021 we see that median
household income adjusted for inflation
was already higher we don't know what it
will be in 2022 but that's a much faster
growth in terms of the income recovery
there's a lot of reasons for that
obviously the Great Recession was caused
by different factors than a global
pandemic so different economic effects
but we can see if you look on slide 40
that the federal efforts to stimulate
the economy were really targeted at some
of the most effective stimulus this is
modeling from Moody's Analytics that
looks over the course of 2021 and
estimates what is the dollar value in
economic output for each dollar invested
by the federal government in certain
programs and you can see food assistance
was at the top and the federal aid
packages did boost food assistance
unemployment compensation Aid to State
and local governments earned income tax
credit and child tax credit expansions
those are all things that stimulate the
economy in the short term
so we can see that likely had some
significant spurring effect for economic
growth
the uh however if you look at slide 41
these are data from New Hampshire
showing the percentage of adults since
middle of 2020 unfortunately we don't
have these Data before that the
percentage of adults reporting it's been
somewhat or very difficult to pay for
usual household expenses in the last
seven days and you can see that that
percentage especially since the monthly
child tax credits have ended and
inflation really started to pick up in
the first half of 2022 that it has
become more difficult according to New
Hampshire adults about a third and a
little bit more than a third in some
months reported that it was somewhat or
very difficult to pay for those usual
household expenses so that doesn't
portend well for the economy especially
folks who are having that difficulty but
if we look at slide 42 and I know there
was some discussion about this last week
this is the amount of additional savings
that households have by income quartile
in the second quarter of 2022 relative
to what the researchers at the Federal
Reserve would have projected based on
pre-pandemic Trends and we can see that
those their additional savings across
groups this is not necessarily across
every household in each group but across
groups that's a good cushion that's a
good set of assets to go into more
uncertain Economic Times with because
that's likely supports state that likely
supports consumption expenditures and uh
and means that households that may face
headwinds from both inflation which has
likely already eroded a fair bit of this
and an economic slowdown we'll see that
these savings going into that period
with these savings likely helps of
course with the lowest savings at the
bottom quartile that means that the
households that have lower incomes and
are probably least likely able to
weather an economic downturn are coming
in with the smallest number of assets
and before the we're using 2019 or
estimating for 2019 and using 2019 data
about 26 percent of New Hampshire
households did not have two thousand
dollars in emergency savings according
to estimates from the urban Institute
um if I should I keep going is that
I think we can keep going for now yeah
and if no one objects sorry Governor
okay with that
okay okay great
John do we excuse me Jen do we know um
Department of Employment Security
oh they are okay
um let's um try to wrap up in the next
three or four minutes sure great
absolutely
um one thing that I'll say in slide 43
is the only sort of national
macroeconomic slide that I have the last
few months of data the last five months
or data or so have been quite
encouraging if we're looking for a
so-called soft Landing for the economy
um because we've seen the uh rate of job
growth slow but still remain a robust
over 200 000 a month and we've seen the
rate of inflation slow year over year
now it's still too high uh but it is uh
coming down or appears to be coming down
from where it was before
on slide 44 we can see that growth State
product again our state version of gross
domestic product has recovered faster
than employment from the pandemic that
pandemic employment that pre-pandemic
high unemployment level is still
something we're sort of getting to at
this point whereas grow State product
has increased substantially labor force
constraints are probably keeping that
from growing further they've probably
slowed that it probably has slowed
growth in employment as well as slowed
growth State product overall
and one thing I do want to mention I
know you talked some last week about uh
particularly that 20 to 34 age group and
the lower participation rate in the 20
to 34 age group I do want to emphasize
that child care is likely a big part of
that we have some data especially
associated with the pandemic
um and some of those pandemic era data
collections that suggest that child care
disruptions have been a big component of
holding people back out of the workforce
and and child care cost is really
significant particularly for households
with lower incomes as you can see on the
chart
and I also want to note that long-term
demographics are likely part of what
we're seeing as the slower growth in the
labor force over time
um so the state released some
projections last year that about 30
percent more than 30 percent of the
state population will be 60 years or
older by 2030 that doesn't mean that
folks in the 60 year old or category
will not be participating in the
workforce many of them will be but it
does mean that it's there's a higher
likelihood that a significant portion of
the population will be either retiring
or reducing their engagement in the
workforce particularly as you get
significantly older than age 60. so that
means Child Care Access housing
availability affordability and education
will all be key to supporting the
current and future Workforce so some key
takeaways
um State revenues are relatively diverse
Federal funding is an important part of
it the business profits tax has
substantially increased in importance in
the terms of the total state revenue pie
in recent years and has been you know
potentially that's a potentially
volatile Revenue Source in a recession
or a Slowdown because corporate profits
may be more responsive to that than say
business Enterprise tax compensation or
employment base or property tax base or
even meals and rentals meals and rentals
tax and real estate transfer tax
revenues have jumped higher in the last
two years relative to that growth may be
slowing as they sort of get back to
trend line or as we see more Supply
constraint on the real estate side
interest in dividends tax revenues will
decline with the phase out with the
reducing rate and then Workforce growth
in the state's economy has been
constrained by long-term demographics
lack of access to child care and limited
housing and I do want to note a
recession is not a certainty there's a
lot of discussion about how a recession
uh is likely to be coming I don't
consider it a certainty uh by any means
but key revenue streams are at risk if a
recession does occur or a significant
economic slowdown and that would limit
resources available to provide services
and support the economy through those
services so there's some additional
resources on the last slide and I'm
happy to take any additional questions
that the chair seeks to allocate time to
so
we can take one or two questions anyone
well seeing none I think we're good
thank you very much great presentation
okay thank you for the opportunity I
foreign can you have the Department of
Employment Security come in if they're
out
oh yeah
yeah
foreign
okay we'll get started with the
Department of Employment Security
presentation a few gentlemen would
introduce yourselves to start that'd be
great
good afternoon Richard laver's Deputy
Commissioner with the Department
Brian gotlab director of the economic
and labor market information Bureau of
um so what we have here we're going to
and first of all thank you for
um inviting us back to finish up the
material that we wanted to cover
um we updated a few slides that Brian
will be covering to capture the most
recent information with the the latest
CPI report that came out at the end of
last week we also tried to add a few
additional slides in response to some
topics that were discussed when we
talked last week so I'll fast forward to
the to where we left off there's a few
newer slides to try to look a little bit
more granular at the child care industry
and some other sectors so you can see
the the progression that they've made or
lack thereof since the prior to the
pandemic and then we'll get into Brian
looking at his forecast
all right
um so this is where we had left off
excuse me uh the presentation is online
too right
thank you okay thank you
okay
um so this slide is where we had left
off this is this had looked at the
difference in labor force participation
by gender in the 25 to 34 year old age
group
um then there there had been some
questions asked about uh Child Care
specifically so we had looked at both
the difference in licensed
establishments as well as employment at
those licensed establishments so this
slide you can see establishments are off
by a little over six percent and the
workforce at those establishments is
down a little over 600 individuals or
about 11
so trying to
be responsive to the questions that were
asked when we last spoke
um and we did uh we decided to put in uh
some uh detail on some uh particular
sectors
um that we had talked about so we had
shown gain and loss from an employment
perspective uh for
um all sectors here in New Hampshire and
what we did here in a series of slides
was just to show the quarterly
progression so pre-pandemic total number
of workers based upon reports filed by
those employers so this is not survey
data this is actual quarterly reports
from those employers that are in that
particular sector and you can see here
I'm looking at retail you'll see in Q4
of 2019 was their pre-pandemic peak of
about 95 000 workers 95 541 and you can
go to the right hand side of the screen
you can see the most recent data we have
here for Q2 of 2022 almost at 88
thousand so you can see how they have
trended from quarter to quarter and
where they are currently compared to
2019 and again this is the actual
employer filings Q2 is the most recent
we have right now so there is a decent
lag with being able to receive that
information and then get it into a
format to publish but here it gives you
that quarterly breakdown and again this
was our retail employers when we look at
hospitals here again you can see you can
look back to 2019 Q4 was their
pre-pandemic Peak just over 30 000
workers and then on the right hand side
of the screen Q2 of 2022 just over 28
000 workers you could see that that
quarterly change where they they did
reach a peak coming out of the pandemic
of 2088 or almost you know 28 900 in Q4
of 2021 and have seen some loss in those
nursing and Residential Care Facilities
again same display of information here
quarterly employment so you can compare
their pre-pandemic peak of of quarter
three of 2019 of about 14 500 employees
to Quarter Two of 2022 at just under 13
200 employees and see that fluctuation
and then restaurants that was a one that
had been a few questions were asked
about those numbers and here you can see
with restaurant employment usually peaks
in that third quarter each year and that
Q3 2019 Peak was fifty three thousand to
sixty seven when you look at Q2 our most
recent information for 2022 down to 50
077 seven if you compare Q2 to Q2 to to
seasonally adjust that you can see that
Q2 of 2019 at about 51 8 and now in Q2
of 2022 at 50 000
77. so slightly slightly down when you
look at Q2 to Q2 but it'll be
interesting to see that third quarter
number for 2022 and to compare that back
to 2019 when that's available which
should be shortly and I think here we
now can move on I think we have a sorry
we have a question representative thank
you so
are the jobs there they're just having
trouble filling them
so we have the jobs we just don't have
the people
yeah the um the the actual postings the
demand
um is up over where it was in in 2019
um and I think we still haven't gotten
to those have we done some of those
slides yet or getting to them I think we
have no okay yeah so we'll be looking at
some of that uh the posting detail for
employers and comparing that back to
2019 so you can see where the demand is
representative almi
have you looked at the thing of
establishments
for uh restaurants I think restaurants
are slightly the one right two
restaurants three restaurants died and
everybody working at them formed their
own restaurant
and then started fighting over the
workers
but I think yep slightly upright yes
slightly up for restaurant employers for
establishments
so um now we'll talk a little bit about
what we see happening in the future
um our Outlook is a little bit kind of
classic
um we're not right now
um of a mind that that the U.S is
inevitably going to fall into recession
that does put us in the minority
category
um uh we'll take you through some slides
to provide some backup to that view
we're not we don't believe we're being
pollyanish we think that there's been
some significant improvements in data
over the last few months it is still
going to be not a particularly good
economic year it could be quite weak the
difference the distinction between a
very weak economy and one that is in
recession will be pretty hard to
distinguish
but the key metric I think is what's
going to happen in the labor market and
we're more optimistic about
um the absence of of decline in
employment than we have been in some
time so
um
I wouldn't take I wouldn't take offense
at anybody who argues that we are going
to fall into a recession I think there's
a reasonable certainly a reasonable case
for that but based on what we see we
don't think that's going to happen so
number one household finances are
actually better positioned to withstand
some of the negative things that are
happening the price shocks inflation and
I say that with one caveat and that's
largely true of middle and upper income
households lower income households
clearly are struggling and I'm sure Phil
provided some of that information so
we're talking in the aggregate so
understand that we certainly understand
there's plenty of households that are
hurting inflation is clearly moderating
and although it's not captured so much
in in the CPI numbers for a number of
reasons that I won't get into rental
increases are starting to slow and we
know housing sales prices are starting
to fall
so that's encouraging and that's a big
part of the CPI by the way shelter is 32
percent of the of the the CPI the labor
force recovering not as fast as we would
like
um but it is recovering and job growth
is slowing and that's actually a good
thing from the Federal Reserve
perspective they're concerned about wage
inflation
and what it would wage price spiral
mod the combination of an increase in
labor force and a slowing of the job
growth will moderate
um the wage wage increases and that will
help put a damper on inflation concerns
here's the biggest I think rationale for
why we can avoid a recession is that we
believe based on what's happened over
the last few years the difficulty that
employers have had in hiring people that
they will be reluctant more reluctant in
a downturn to let go of employees for
fear
they may not be able to rehire when the
economy strengthens
even forecasters who believe the new the
economy is headed for a recession most
believe it will be a mild recession and
in a mild recession
there a lot of businesses will feel that
the risk of letting people go and not
being able to rehire is greater than
holding on to employees
household Financial Obligations
including debt are relatively Low by
historical standards so we enter a
weaker economy with households in a
better position again with the caveat
that lower income households have had to
borrow if you look at credit usage it's
up much more at lower income households
and it is in upper middle and upper
income households corporate debt is also
low banks are well capitalized and
recessions are often really exacerbated
when when banks are weakened and and
very much more reluctant or able to lend
credit is is the fuel for economic
growth we do know that consumer spending
is slowing and likely will continue to
slow but it's still positive year over
year and without
layoffs in large numbers that means
incomes will stay will keep from falling
in in free fall and without that it's
very hard to see a recession on the
horizon if consumers can still spend and
businesses aren't laying off in Mass we
believe it becomes very difficult for
the for the US economy to fall into
recession so that's the scenario let's
take a look at some of the backup of
that because that's a lot of words
one thing that we are that we do know is
that people are not very optimistic and
recessions are fundamentally about a
loss of confidence so when businesses
aren't confident about the economy they
don't hire typically when they're very
concerned about the economy or the
economy starts they lay off we don't
think the layoffs are going to come
they'll come but they won't come in
large as large in numbers so businesses
aren't hiring and consumers are very
concerned as they at least indicate they
are this is a universe the blue line is
University of Michigan consumer
sentiment index so one that I favor
generally does a better job than the
consumer confidence survey in assessing
how individual households feel about
their financial circumstances
the problem is is that over the last
year or more
despite the fact that households have
indicated that they're not very
confident they've still spent so there's
been a bigger Gap in what they say or
how they feel about the economy and
what's they're actually doing in this
economy
so our concern has been and you see it
all the time CEOs
saying there's going to be a recession
some big Bank CEO saying we're headed
for a recession or some billionaire who
runs the electric vehicle company says
we're definitely going down you know
falling off a cliff it becomes
problematic and people believe that and
if they believe that then they become
pessimists they can and start cutting
back so I did mention the household
Financial Obligations ratio what's that
that's the the things that households
have to pay
mortgages rents Etc
insurance payments as a percentage of
their disposable income and what you see
here is that these shaded areas are
periods of recession
right now as of the third quarter
We Begin any slowdown in a much better
position than than we have been heading
into prior recessions and again caveat
lower income households much different
circumstance and it is rising as you see
there and I expect it will rise but at
least we begin a period where the
mentioned that inflation is heading down
this is probably the most optimistic and
if you look at the most recent three
months or so and annualize that
inflation would be about three and a
representative plett yeah that sounds
better in my view than it is isn't it
true that you had a hundred ten percent
inflation a year ago that's 1.1 times
safer than costs you have five percent
inflation this year that's another 1.05
so you compound them is that your
understanding it
clearly prices are much higher yeah but
they keep going up so it doesn't unless
the deflation they don't go back
absolutely and some things are are
beginning to deflate the the
prices do generally always rise
so we expect that and there there's a
compounding effect
inflation peaked at I believe 9.5 we're
now down
to
6.5 and if you look at the last three
months an annualized ad it's somewhere
over three and a half percent I do
believe that by the end of 2023 we'll be
under four percent on a on a
year-over-year basis so it's clearly
much higher than we would like higher
prices are not good but what inflation
is is a constant acceleration of of
prices and we're not seeing that we're
starting to see the a decline
and this just has the Northeast as well
as the U.S Northeast is a little bit
lower a couple of reasons for that one I
think Believe It or Not housing prices
and shelter prices are a little bit
lower in the Northeast not lower but
they haven't risen as much because
population hasn't grown places some
places in the west Boise Idaho
has had the fastest shelter rise in
shelter costs one year it was almost 30
percent so so for places so places where
there's been a big population growth Etc
um have have had seen the biggest so and
that's again 32 percent of the CPI
that's played so also gasoline prices
High everywhere Northeast we tend to
drive a little bit less we don't have as
far to go so that plays into it as well
uh
retail sales
somebody's calling me on something I
Phil
wants to disagree
um I mentioned I mentioned that retail
sales have um they're slowing this is I
should have I didn't put the title in
here but that's year-over-year increase
in retail sales some of this obviously
has to do with Rises and prices but it
is still
positive year over year so while there's
a slowing and there's two lines there
one is the total retail sales blue the
orange line is retail sales excluding
automobiles automobiles have been a drag
on retail sales why because there hasn't
been much in the way of inventory now as
interest rates rise that will put up
probably a further damper on on on sales
of automobiles but still it's positive
expect it will it will slow somewhat
more
this chart I love
um one of the things that we try to do
is get unique data for New Hampshire and
one of the things that we've done in the
pandemic is try to get very high
frequency timely data this data it comes
from open table which is a company that
takes restaurant reservations in every
state and this is a daily metric of the
number of seeded restaurant it can be
walk-ins or it could be reservations
that are made of the same group of
restaurants and it compares the current
date number of reservations with the
same date in 2019 so pre-pandemic versus
current and what you see is
relatively early December of 2020 early
2021 you know restaurant reservations
restaurants were closed people were
reluctant to do it 60 or more it has
recovered
and interestingly New Hampshire is well
above where it was in 2019. why is this
important because in a real downturn one
of the first things that people cut back
on is dining out
you know when you're when they're
looking to cut back they cut back on
clearly
um that hasn't yet been the case in New
Hampshire so people in New Hampshire
um are are still spending at a fairly
good clip one of the charts that we
didn't include here is
um assessment of the number of Google
searches on the word recession which
tends to correlate pretty well with
people's confidence level New Hampshire
is a little bit better than the U.S and
this data also indicates that and what
we're constantly looking for real-time
indicators we we can't look at
indicators that are a month or two
months or six months old and really have
a sense of where we are and where we're
going in the near term
um I know you heard from uh Dr Ken
Johnson
I don't know exactly what he said
I have generally heard him suggest that
New Hampshire isn't quite in the
negative as bad in demographic State as
some people would argue I've argued that
for almost two decades now we had a
period where we had net out migration
for a number of reasons it has picked up
again net domestic in migration people
move wanted to move to New Hampshire
that accelerated a bit during the
pandemic and it did so because people
wanted to get away from more densely
populated areas there's a lot of them in
the Northeast they had remote work
opportunities that helped one of the
constraints that we face
it's a really positive demographic for
us really helps us address our
demographic issues because New
Hampshire's labor force grows largely by
in-migration
so when more people are moving here
that's good the constraint that we have
is the availability of Housing and that
acts as I think that's one of the
reasons why this most recent year was a
little bit lower
beyond that when we look at who's moving
here
Vermont and Maine each saw net domestic
immigration Vermont had lost people for
10 years to other states
the most recent couple of years it's
actually seen in migration Maine has
seen a little bit higher net in
migration than New Hampshire but New
Hampshire benefits because our
demographics of those who move into the
state are a little bit different it's
trending younger
we see here the percentage of
individuals who move to New Hampshire
adults not counting college students
because people under 25 move from state
to state
go to college
forget about them think about people age
25 and above
New Hampshire has by far the the largest
percentage of people ages 25 to 34 in
that group almost half the people adults
who have moved to New Hampshire and who
are 25 and above are age 25 to 34 and a
smaller percentage of of older residents
made under contrast more people but in
older demographic
even better news
for our long-term demographics
is the percentage New Hampshire had this
the fifth largest percentage increase in
population of 25 to 29 year olds of any
state in the nation between 2015 and
2021.
that is quite a surprise
we had always been attractive to sort of
early career married couple families
with children
we attracted a lot of individuals from
the Northeast and that cat in that age
group increasingly we're seeing it
an uptick in 25 29 25 to 34 year olds
moving into the state and if I looked at
one year earlier 2014 to 2020 when we're
actually the second highest but I did
not want to cherry pick the data because
I looked at that after the fact so but I
did cherry pick because I wanted to
mention it but that's very very positive
but the the importance of this is that
you know you hear a narrative that New
Hampshire has one foot in the grave that
we're the oldest state we're not by
median age and we have a higher median
age for one important reason we have
very low birth rates either New
Hampshire or Vermont historically have
the lowest birth rates in the nation
and the easiest way to keep your median
age from rising or keep it low is to add
people at age zero and we do not do that
so we rely on people moving into the
state these demographics that I'm
talking about rise of the increase in 25
to 29 year olds that a migration of
younger demographic will help
it won't keep us from aging but it'll
help slow that increase in the median
age of our state
I did mention that we are in the
minority when it comes to assessing the
probability of recession this just came
out
today I believe maybe yeah it was today
the latest economic survey of economists
from The Wall Street Journal they survey
71 economists for their probability of
recession the mean probability and it
varied quite a bit
is 61 percent
so so majority of economists believe
that the U.S economy is headed for
recession
um it had it notice at the end there it
has come down a little bit and that's
because we're getting a little bit more
positive
um economic news
so last slide
what do we think is going to happen I
will say this is our job growth forecast
2022 we think we'll be around 2.7
percent that will change we'll we have
estimated numbers now it will change
based on
um
a benchmarking process that matches our
records for employers that they that
submit to us the number of employees and
their wages once we match that up or the
Bureau of Labor statistic will have a
better more accurate number but it'll be
somewhere around there
moving forward our forecast is that New
Hampshire will have somewhat under one
percent employment growth that will vary
also once we get the Benchmark numbers
that forecast will likely change we
think we'll be a little bit slower
than the
U.S and that's not because we have a
weaker economy it's because we have we
are more labor constrained and I did I
wanted to go back to one slide because
we I thought we had talked about the
yeah
so this is just a a chart that looks at
we showed you this once before the job
openings rate which is very high has
been a little bit higher than the US
it's right around the U.S now but very
high compared to where it has
historically been and the job job
openings and the job higher rate so the
difference between the number of
openings and the hirings is what we call
the unfilled job openings rate and you
see how much it's jumped it's still
extremely elevated so there's still lots
of opportunity out there there's lots of
jobs there aren't enough individuals New
Hampshire is more labor constrained
going back again to the labor force
growth we're still about one percent
below where we were prior to the
pandemic and number of people in the
labor force the U.S is just about back
to where they were prior to the pandemic
and with that
I'll stop
thank you that was a lot of good
information do we have any questions uh
representative fellows
um one question I have is do you have
any information on how many residents of
New Hampshire are employed
out of state I know some of them are
commuting to to Massachusetts mostly and
then some of them might just be working
for companies that you know they're
Brian can address uh some of the remote
work piece but historically
um we have about 120 000 people
um that live in New Hampshire
um that are are commuting out we have
another 80 000 that are commute that
live outside New Hampshire that are
commuting in so we tend we are we have a
net uh gain with uh two uh neighbors to
the uh East and the West with Maine and
Vermont we actually draw in more workers
from those States than New Hampshire
sees leave to go work in those States
but we have a net loss with
Massachusetts
um that's and that's historically
um what we what we've been seeing but on
the on the remote work side
yeah we don't have a uh a hard measure
of the number of people who work
remotely we have it
I will say that U.S Bureau of Labor
Statistics is working is now
beginning to ask workers on their
monthly survey which is the basis of the
unemployment rate and labor force
numbers is beginning to ask people who
they survey about their remote work they
had been doing that in the pandemic but
they were asking the question in a way
that
they specifically said are you working
remote because of the pandemic and now
we're not really if there is such a
thing as a post-pandemic world
um there's a lot of reasons why people
are working remotely and that will be
permanently we do have speaking of high
frequency metrics and this unfortunately
stopped about a month and a half ago we
were looking at Google Mobility data
Google tracks all of us if you leave
your location on I don't but it tracks
where we go and it so it was listing by
state and by County actually
how many trips were made to workplaces
versus again pre-pandemic numbers I've
tracked that all the way through about
November of this year of 2022 past year
and New Hampshire was down somewhere
between 15 and 20 percent so that gives
us an indication not that people are
working remotely all the time but on a
daily basis
about 15 to 20 percent fewer trips to
workplaces were being made so that tells
you that remote work hybrid work is here
to stay but it does not tell us whether
necessarily those are New Hampshire
workers or whether those are you know
our workers from other state so
hopefully we'll have some better
information on that but we're estimating
that it's going to be somewhere around
15 and or a little bit higher people who
work remotely and likely we're going to
see more of what you refer to
because New Hampshire is an attractive
place to live unfortunately the Greater
Boston metro area
is pays a whole lot more for equivalent
occupations so that's a draw and if you
um it you know it can be easy to do to
to make that choice live in New
Hampshire work for a Massachusetts
company
all set or you have one more okay oh
follow-up yeah representative fellows
okay
another question so my other question is
retail sales are are steady we're not
losing anything in retail sales do you
know how much of that is like things
that are being ordered online from
Amazon versus in our local stores
we don't know that for New Hampshire
particularly we do know that
um you know the Department of Commerce
does produce retail sales numbers but it
also produces online retail sales
numbers and that has been increasing
increased the most and accelerated
during the pandemic it was accelerating
prior to the pandemic you know brick and
mortar retail was starting to decline
prior to the pandemic the pandem
pandemic accelerated that and that's one
of the reasons why you see those numbers
employ retail employment numbers decline
but it has it it the rate of increases
slowed it just peaked during the
pandemic because nobody was shopping at
Brick and Mortar very few people
given the choice were and there were
fewer opportunities to do it in in brick
and mortar
yeah they're still going up they will
likely continue to go up I don't think
that's a trend that that we're likely to
to um you know to see go away much like
we're not going to see remote work go
away that you know they'll settle in
terms of the increase the rate of
increase but we're not going to see a
reversal
and you see a lot of you'll see that's
why you're seeing Maul you know a lot of
empty stores and malls
um and you know a whole lot of empty
sounds good any other last minute
questions
okay seeing none thank you very much
so um we're done for today
um as representative Sanborn had
mentioned our next meeting will be on
Monday
and that'll come out in the calendar
uh this week so you'll see the timing on
that that'll be um
those will be uh info those will be
Revenue we'll be doing Revenue estimates
on Monday and Wednesday and Tuesday will
questions so as far as you know are we
not planning to exec on anything
or uh as far as I know but I'm but
um exec could happen at any time I know
as of right now there was there was no
rush but um
I don't know do you have a what are your
thoughts
turn your microphone
the arrangement the way it's been set up
is that the chair and the ranking decide
together whether there's going to be an
exec
and I haven't heard anything yet either
I would say the odds of it are are slim
at this point representative Platt I
would just urge executing as we go along
my last committee Science and Technology
went they waited to the end and they
made awfully long but uh days
legislatively so if we can exec them
earlier to get them to through the
speaker's office and onto the floor for
disposition we're not jammed at the end
and I think anything as as
representative Almy mentioned the chair
and she will will decide and
I I think anything that's exact in the
immediate future meaning next week would
be something that pretty obviously
there's there's a lot of support on both